Das ist wunderschön.
Ich habe aktuell eine
Homekit-Kamera zu Hause.
Und die hat mir heute
eine Notification geschickt,
dass sie die Bewegung erkannt hat.
Da hat deine Katze
eine Kiste umgekippt. Warte, warte, warte.
Und ja.
Jetzt ist sie aufgefallen.
Und dann konnte ich zuschauen.
Eine halbe Stunde haben die beiden Katzen sich an der
umgefallenen Kiste zu schaffen
und angefangen haben, das Styropor rauszugraben.
Toll.
Du sitzt so auf Arbeit
und denkst dir so, fuck damn it.
Ich kann über die Kamera auch
reden, aber das ist weird.
Reagieren die Katzen da drauf?
Ich hab's noch nicht probiert, ich find das weird.
Ich hab jetzt auch eine Katze.
In Minecraft.
Ich spiele seit ein paar Wochen wieder.
Ernsthaft? Achso, stimmt.
Ich bin so ins Minecraft-Loch gefallen.
Können wir zusammen irgendwo Minecraft spielen?
Uh, apropos, ich habe eine coole Welt.
Die hat ein riesiges Loch.
Natürlich generated.
Also, ich habe einen Minecraft-Server.
Den machst du nur manchmal an, habe ich gehört.
Den habe ich aus Mangel an...
An...
Wie heißt das?
Reliability Requirements.
auf meinem Desktop-Computer
da drüben laufen.
Und das spielt auch schon eine weitere Person mit.
Und als Einpick
wollte ich aufzählen,
wusstest du, und vielleicht hast du dieses Feature auch schon,
dass Fritz OS
seit einigen Versionen des
Yasu-Ubels einfach macht,
einen Wireguard VPN aufzumachen.
Ich dachte, du meinst, dass du auf einer Fritzbox
einen Minecraft-Server betreiben kannst.
Das wäre großartig.
Ich hatte den vorher auf einem Raspberry Pi 3 oder 4 laufen.
Ja.
Und der ist abgestürzt, der ist nicht hinterhergekommen.
Deswegen habe ich es dann auf den Mac Mini da drüben gekriegt.
Cool.
Das funktioniert super, solange ich zu Hause bin und auf dem Gerät spiele.
Wenn ich nicht da bin, dann kriege ich immer Pings mit,
kannst du bitte den Computer wieder aufhecken?
Kannst du bitte den Computer wieder aufhecken?
Aber, und das hat ganz gut funktioniert,
weil du kannst einfach jemandem die Capability
geben, hier hast du eine Wireguard
Config, um in mein Heimnetzwerk reinzukommen.
Du, ich hatte witzigerweise genau dasselbe
letztens. Und
du musst keinerlei Ports freigeben, oder?
Ja, das ist so toll.
Wir wollten zu dritt
meinen Test spielen, dieses Open Source Minecraft.
Das wäre quasi dieselbe Idee.
Das hab ich vorher lange gespielt, ja.
Und ein Freund saß bei mir zu Hause, und der andere Freund
saß nicht bei mir zu Hause.
Und witzigerweise der andere Freund
Kollegen, also hi Julius,
und
dann hatten wir kurz überlegt, wie schaffen wir es denn,
dass wir zusammen spielen können, ich kann ja nicht einfach so ein Server
öffnen, das ist ein freier Internet irgendwie, sonst wie.
Du kannst auch für N Euro
im Monat kannst du dir auf Minecraft Realms
einfach sowas machen. Ja, und es gibt ja auch so kostenlose
Server über Aternos oder wie diese Plattform
heißt, aber, oder du
machst kurz N-Crog auch wahrscheinlich
oder so, aber dann dachte ich mir,
wäre das nicht einfach super chill? Ich weiß doch, du hast mir
mal gesagt, dass es diese Wireguard-Sache gibt, ich nutze das
selber sehr, sehr häufig.
Wir haben noch einen anderen Use Case, über den wir in dieser Sendung
reden wollen. Kommen wir gleich dazu.
Aber da habe ich auch einfach kurz eine zweite
WireGuard-Config konfiguriert, habe die dem geschickt.
Hab die Julius geschickt. Julius hat
die aktiviert bei sich, weil der WireGuard-Client
auch super easy und cool zu nutzen ist.
Auf Nicht-Dinux, wo du dem aus irgendwelchen
Gründen-Sudo-Rechte geben musst.
Und dann haben wir einfach
spielen können. So effortless. Am Ende habe ich die
Config einfach wieder gelöscht. Und das macht mich einfach glücklich, dass es
so einfach war. Das ist wie mit Hamachi früher.
Genau, genau. Und ich habe diese
Datei genommen und über
iMessage verschickt oder per,
nee, es ging nicht, dann ging es nicht zu importieren.
Dann habe ich sie per E-Mail
an die Gmail-Adresse der Person
geschickt und
dann habe ich gleich
eine weitere hinzugefügt und als wir das
nächste Mal uns in person gesehen haben, habe ich
die neue PR-Job
übertragen, weil
die an Google verpestete Config
ja ein Private Key beinhaltet.
Ja, dauerhaft will ich die nicht rumliegen
lassen, wenn die auf Google-Servern lag. Das fühlt sich
falsch an. Auch wenn da 100%
nichts passiert, aber das fühlt sich falsch an.
Sehr falsch. Genau.
Ja,
wir können gerne auch mal...
Ach stimmt, wir haben noch gar keinen Start gemacht.
Hi Hendrik. Hey Kian.
Weißt du, was wir schon lange nicht mehr gemacht haben?
Eine Folge aufnehmen.
Willkommen bei Akronomisierbar Folge 57.
Krass.
Das ist Akronomisierbar Quantum.
Ah, die Quantum-Folge.
Die ist extra schnell. Die läuft heute in eurem Podcast auf 5.
Die sind rustisch in dieser Folge.
Oh Mann, ey.
Ja, was gibt's denn bei dir sonst Neues?
Wir müssen uns unbedingt...
Wir brauchen eine neue Sektion Minecraft-Tipps.
Wir können auch meinen Test-Tipps...
Mindtest ist ein tatsächlich sehr, sehr cooles Spiel.
Ich hab das seit bestimmt
sechs Jahren oder acht Jahren nicht mehr.
Nee, ich mein Mindtest.
Ja, Mindtest.
Ach so.
Minecraft hab ich auch eine Weile jetzt, also ich hab's vor kurzem wieder entdeckt
und es gibt so viel in diesem Spiel,
was ich noch nie gesehen hab.
Da gibt's irgendwelche Mobs, noch nie was von gehört.
Ich weiß, in Mindtest gab's einen Screwdriver, der war sehr praktisch.
Was kannst du mit dem machen?
Damit kannst du Blöcke, die du falsch rum platziert hast,
in situ drehen.
Okay, das ist stark.
Und das hätte ich bei Minecraft manchmal gerne.
Das ist stark. Scheiß Treppen.
Eben.
Nur Treppen.
Ausschließlich Treppen.
Furchtbar.
Also das ist ein Feature, was ich
gerne auch bei Minecraft hätte.
Ja, wahrscheinlich geht das irgendwie.
Who knows?
Wir könnten uns über
Wie baust du ein Haus?
Ich kann nicht gut bauen.
Ich habe schon drei Häuser gebaut und ich ärgere mich immer noch.
Ich habe schon wieder
irgendwie so gekriegt, dass das Dach
nicht gerade drauf ist. Deswegen baue ich schon
seit immer, seitdem ich Minecraft spiele,
Häuser in Berge rein.
Also wohnst du einfach in einer Höhle?
Ich wohne nur in Höhlen.
Ja, ja.
Ich bin ein Höhlenmensch.
Das ist das natürlich auch nicht schlecht.
Da kannst du dann den Boden noch mit Holz auskleiden,
vielleicht noch schöne Wände reinmachen, hier unter eine Säule
und eine Farm. Das fühlt sich cool an,
weil Höhlen sind toll. Ich spiele auch gerne Dwarf Fortress.
Vielleicht sind Höhlen einfach so ein tolles Ding.
Also ich bin ja so gerne Seefahrer.
Ich habe jetzt an meinen Locations schon 17 Boote rumliegen.
Und ich erkunde die Welt auch ausschließlich auf dem Seeweg.
Das ist auch einfach effizienter.
Es ist schnell, man sieht viel, man kommt gut rum, man kann die unterschiedlichen Biomes finden.
Genau.
Und manchmal hast du es aber so, dass so ein Fluss einfach unterbrochen ist an einer Stelle.
Und dann setze ich mich hin und grabe da irgendwie 20 mal 20 Blöcke aus.
Und dann sitzt du da mit dem Eimer, um die Strömung wegzumachen.
Ja, das ist scheiße.
Eine coole Wassersimulation würde dem Spiel auch echt gut tun.
Also es wirklich so eine Flüssigkeitssimulation hat,
wo das Wasser ordentlich so sich verbreitet
und nicht einfach diese komische Blockphysik hat.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber dann könntest du das vielleicht nicht mehr so als Sprungtuch verwenden.
Okay, safe nicht.
Das geht dann schief.
Aber es wäre cool, wenn es solche Mods gibt.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht gibt es sowas.
Sicherlich gibt es einen Mindtest.
Das gibt es wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie.
Mindtest ist ja quasi Bedrock Edition.
Was?
Also, Mindtest ist, ich glaube, der Catchphrase von Mindtest war, dass es Minecraft in C++ ist.
Ach so, okay. Aber Mindtest ist ja noch viel mehr als das.
Das Spiel zu starten, ist ja auch witzig.
Du startest erstmal diesen Mindtest-Launcher, der schneller startet als mein Mail-Client.
Diese Software startet instant.
Ja, ist ja nichts drin.
Ja, ja, aber ich finde es trotzdem krass.
Ich bin nicht auf meinem Rechner, was so schnell startet wie der Mindtest-Launcher.
Und dann musst du aber ein Spiel
quasi als Runtime noch da reinladen.
Und das ist dann beispielsweise
das normale Mindtest-Base-Game.
Oder halt auch eine andere
Implementierung oder Art und Weise oder gemoddete
Versionen davon. Genau, da gibt's
super viele Mods auf jeden Fall.
Unter anderem, ich glaub,
Mine-Clone heißt das. Das ist dann das, was
möglichst nah an Vanilla Minecraft
ist. Also auch in der Optik
und in der Bedienung und in den Features,
die die Welten halt hergeben.
Aber es gibt auch zig andere.
Also das ist da sehr, sehr frei.
Es ist quasi bloß die Simulation oder die
Spielregeln.
Ich glaube, ein bisschen UI hängt da dran und
vor allem auch die World Generation.
Aber im Detail kenne ich mich damit
nicht aus. Hast du irgendwelche Shader
installiert oder spielst du? Ich wollte mal
dieses Fancy Minecraft, das mit den
Raidcasts und dem Fancy Wasser.
Ich habe noch nicht probiert.
Bei die Sonnenuntergänge, das wäre einfach schon geil.
Vor allem, was ich am liebsten mache,
das ist so noch mehr als Höhlen,
sind Unterwasserhöhlen
mit Glasdach. Baue ich irgendwie immer wieder.
Wie kriegst du das Wasser daraus?
Vorsichtig.
Also meistens
tunnel ich von unten das Meer an
und dann baue ich einfach ein Glasdach rein,
während ich geflutet werde, weil das sind ja noch keine
Wasserblöcke in dem Moment.
Die kann ich dann nach oben wieder abblocken, das ist
sehr mühsam und dann fließt es unten und versickert
das einfach weg.
Genau, also versickern ist
zu hoch als Konzept.
Ich merke das jedes Mal, ich möchte
die Strömung wegmachen irgendwo, weil
das irgendwie zu wenig Wasser ist an der einen
Stelle und dann kippe ich einfach oben drüber, dass es
reinläuft und denke mir, damit habe ich es
gefixt, aber damit habe ich es nicht gefixt.
Und nebenbei habe ich immer das Wiki auf,
weil ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht weiß, wie ich spiele und
schaue mir dann nach, wie mache ich eigentlich das, wie craft
ich das und das und ich habe das gefunden, was kann man
damit machen. Und Wassersdorf ist das für ein Block noch
nie gehört. Deep Slate
Koppel? Ja. What the fuck ist das?
Ja, ja. Gibt es das schon immer? Genau.
Und was ich jetzt, weil du gerade gesagt hast,
du machst Sachen unter Wasser.
Ich habe neulich erst gelernt, dass man mit
Blöcken unter Wasser
atmen kann, wenn man sich drauf hockt.
What? Also diese leuchtenden
Dinger, wenn du drauf tauchst,
da kommt ja so ein Blubber, die da aufsteigen
und wenn du dich da drauf kauerst,
dann geht deine Luft wieder hoch.
Wie cool. Und ich dachte, ich frag dich mal,
ich hab nämlich noch von irgendeinem
anderen Trick, ich schieb mir
manchmal ewig vor mir her nachzugucken,
wie es wirklich geht, aber ich hab von irgendeinem anderen Trick
gehört, dass man was mit
Schildkröteneiern irgendwas bauen kann,
dass man unter Wasser atmen kann, aber das hab ich noch nie, weißt du
sowas? Nein. Also ich weiß
gerade so, dass es Schildkröten gibt.
Aber nur, weil ich bei anderen Leuten
gesehen habe. Ich habe im Miener keine
Schildkröten gesehen.
Also ich spiele Minecraft. Schildkröten sind wirklich
sauber simuliert. Die legen nämlich
Eier und dann schwimmen
die weg und dann legen die ihre Eier
immer wieder genau dort, wo sie selber gehätscht
sind. Oh, wie cool. Ja.
Das heißt, wenn du es irgendwie schaffst,
die Eier
bei dir irgendwie hatchen zu lassen, an deinem
kleinen Fluss oder sowas. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert.
Okay, das wär toll.
Okay, also wir haben ab jetzt in jeder Folge
akronomisierbar eine Sektion
Neues, was nicht unbedingt Neues
und Cooles aus Minecraft. Ihr kriegt super viel
Minecraft-Content auf YouTube, aber
Sachen, die Kean und Hendrik über Minecraft
gelernt haben.
Das ist ja cool.
Witzig. Wir müssen auf jeden Fall
mal zusammenspielen. Wir sind ja nicht die richtige Minecraft-Audience.
Wir sind ja älter als das Spiel selber.
Das geht dir gar nicht.
Ja, also, ja.
Also so viel zu coolen Dingen, die man mit einem WireGuard VPN Setup machen kann.
Man kann Gäste zum Spielen einladen.
Ja, das ist voll toll.
Man kann auch viele andere tolle Sachen machen, wenn wir schon die Überleitung jetzt finden wollen.
Genau, wofür nutzt du denn deine WireGuard Konfiguration sonst noch?
Also ich weiß es von dir, dass du es so genutzt hast.
Ich nutze es tatsächlich aktiv nicht mehr gerade dafür.
Nämlich haben wir als anderes Thema auf unserer Liste uns Home Assistant mit widmen wollen heute.
Weil du erzählst mir ja schon seit Jahren von einem tollen Home Assistant Setup.
Und ich kriege es mit jedes Mal, wenn ich zu denen nach Hause komme, dass die Lichter blinken, wenn sich meine Geräte in dein Wi-Fi einlösen.
Oh ja, das ist der Flash, wenn mein Gäste-Wi-Fi angeht.
Und ich habe vor kurzem jetzt endlich auch den Absprung geschafft.
Ich kam mal drauf, ich könnte meinen Raspi mal wieder beleben.
Oh, was machen wir denn damit?
Ach na klar, Home Assistant will ich da schon länger ausprobieren.
Habe mir Home Assistant aufgesetzt und dachte mir, ja, vielleicht ist es eine lustige Spielerei fürs Wochenende.
Aber am Ende bleibe ich doch bei HomeKit, weil es läuft stabil.
Ich habe drei Wochen lang alles in Home Assistant reingehangen.
Ich habe so viel Spaß mit Home Assistant gehabt.
Es ist so viel mächtiger als HomeKit,
das wusste ich anfangs gar nicht, was man damit alles machen kann.
Du kannst damit Grafana ersetzen.
Es sind ein paar Sachen, finde ich, ein bisschen unschöner
als in HomeKit gelöst.
Ein paar wenige Sachen, gerade wenn, also die Automation sind mächtig,
aber auch teilweise echt mühsam einzustellen.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, du hast einfach so viel mehr Möglichkeiten.
Das ist krass.
Mal ganz kurz, was ist Home Assistant?
Home Assistant ist eine Software,
die man sich auf dem Raspberry Pi installiert.
Oder irgendwo installiert.
Ich habe anfangs erst auf meinem NAS installiert mitlaufen.
Zum Beispiel. Ich habe einen Raspberry Pi 4
dafür stehen. Genau.
So ein Raspberry bietet dir die coole Möglichkeit,
dass sie da, also
wahrscheinlich kriegst du das irgendwie auch auf dem NAS mitzulaufen,
aber mein Raspberry kann halt Bluetooth, mein NAS nicht.
Und somit kannst du auch direkt über Bluetooth
mit bestimmter Hardware sprechen. Ah ja, das habe ich zum Beispiel
noch nie ausprobiert. Du siehst hier,
ich mache mal meinen Home Assistant auf.
Und zumindest, es hat
tonnenweise Integration für unterschiedlichste
Sensoren und Geräte,
die sich damit steuern lassen.
Man kann damit Lichter an und aus machen.
Das ist so der Basic-Use-Gest.
Man kann aber auch tonnenweise
andere Sachen machen.
Also sie haben Integration
für alles, unter anderem auch beispielsweise
für die Fritzbox. Und kannst dann aus
deiner Fritzbox nicht nur so Sachen auslesen,
wie aktuelle Upload- und Download-Geschwindigkeiten
oder generell Zahlen für
wie viel habe ich diesen Monat schon runtergeladen,
was ein schönes Stat zum Game-Effine ist,
die auf über Terabyte treiben.
Also die Abstraktion, die HomeKit
spricht, sind
Devices und Sensoren.
Und die Devices können in Kategorien fallen,
dass die togglebar sind
oder Werte haben.
Und jedes Gerät, was du anschließt,
was irgendwelche Informationen outputtet,
kannst du
plotten.
Ich sehe zum Beispiel historische Werte
über den Batterieladestand meines Handys.
Oder witzigerweise, also wenn du die HomeKit-App,
HomeKit, wenn du die Home Assistant-App auf deinem Telefon hast,
liest die als Sensoren natürlich auch ganz viele Daten
über dein Telefon aus, zum Beispiel deinen Step-Counter,
was ein bisschen, also ich brauche es nicht, aber es geht.
Aber du kannst es auch disablen,
du musst der App natürlich keine Zugriffe auf die Daten geben,
aber gleichzeitig, wenn du die Daten,
es ist ja eben ein self-gehostetes Ding meistens,
damit du dir reinspeicherst,
kannst du halt auch Automationen draufschmeißen.
Und das klingt erstmal ganz lame,
aber du könntest zum Beispiel sagen,
dass deine Schreibtischlampe rot wird,
wenn dein Handyakku leer wird.
Als Beispiel wäre absolut kein Thema zu automatisieren.
Oder mit der Fritzbox-Integration, was ganz witzig ist,
ist, du kannst an den Connection-State von bestimmten Mac-Adressen Automationen hängen.
Und wenn sich ein bestimmter Freund bei mir zu Hause meinen WiFi einloggt,
sprich, wenn er vorbeikommt, geht in meinem Home Assistant zwei Minuten-Timer los,
dass er auch wirklich safe in der Wohnung angekommen ist,
dann blinken alle Lampen blau und mein HomePod sagt,
Achtung, Achtung, ein Cyber-Alarm wurde ausgelöst.
Ah ja, das hast du mir mal so gesehen.
Das war nicht super witzig, dass sowas geht.
Und dann habe ich mich angepasst, also als ich das eingestellt hatte, war ich überzeugt.
Also das ist eine Bullshit-Automation, klar.
Aber ab dem Punkt habe ich angefangen,
da tiefer mit Sachen zu machen
und war voll überzeugt, was alles möglich ist.
Weil du einfach wirklich an jedem Kram was hängen kannst.
Du kannst alles automatisieren.
Alles.
Und das ist einfach so unglaublich mächtig.
Und jetzt habe ich bei mir zu machen.
Also angefangen hat es bei mir,
ich habe mir vor kurzem endlich mal so einen CO2-Sensor für zu Hause gekauft.
Dieses Aranet-Ding.
Weil es auch wirklich ein CO2-Sensor ist und nicht irgendwas anderes misst.
Und dann das umrechtet in CO2.
Und das fand ich an dem Gerät immer ganz cool.
Und weil dieses Gerät keine HomeKit-Integration hatte,
was ich sehr schade fand,
das war für mich der Punkt, wo ich Home Assistant ausprobieren wollte.
Und natürlich kann ich das direkt in meinen Home Assistant reinhängen.
Der Pi spricht direkt darüber.
Und jetzt habe ich hier so ein cooles Gauge-Dings.
Über Bluetooth oder über was?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube nicht.
Wir können das mal strukturieren.
Aber ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Und etwas später mal über Connectivity-Protokolle sprechen.
sondern ich würde gerne erst mal High-Level bleiben.
Also ich habe mir hier so ein Dashboard gebaut.
Und wir können mal Dashboards vergleichen.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen blöd.
Dein Dashboard ist ja fantastisch.
Und man baut sich halt unterschiedliche Widgets mit,
also das hier sind relativ einfach.
Ich glaube, ich kann auf Editieren gehen und dann sieht man,
ich habe vergessen, wie das Ding heißt.
Das ist ein Entity-Card.
Das sind einfach bloß ein paar Sachen aufgelistet.
Können wir davon irgendwie ein Screenshot mit teilen?
Ich kann davon ein Screenshot-Editing, Show Notes tun, ja.
Also das erste ist einfach ein Block mit Szenen.
Das meiste, was ich umschalte, sind Szenen.
Die oberste ist Alles-Aus.
Szenen sind einfach vorkonfigurierte Einstellungen für verschiedene Geräte.
Genau, ich habe eine Szene, die heißt Alles-Aus.
Die ist mein Template für alle anderen.
Da sind alle Geräte drin mit Aus.
Das ist immer super nervig, wenn ich Szenen habe,
wenn ich neue Geräte hinzufüge,
weil ich sie dann quasi zu jeder Szene
mit dem gewünschten Zustand hinzufügen muss.
Manchmal sind Szenen auch hinreichend,
wenn da bloß gewisse Geräte drin sind.
Zum Beispiel habe ich eine Homeoffice-Szene.
Da gehen einfach bloß von den Lampen da um meinen Schreibtisch drum um
alle Lichter auf volle Leistung.
Ja, genau das ist meine Work-Szene.
Die macht genau das gleiche.
In der All-Off-Szene muss alles drin sein.
Und dann sind sie nach Uhrzeiten sortiert.
Early Morning, Evening, Relax, Night, Late Night.
Mir war Night nicht dunkel genug,
dann habe ich es noch dunkler gemacht.
Jetzt habe ich quasi Night und Late Night.
meine Good-Night-Szene, die mache ich an.
Wenn ich die aktiviere, geht alles aus,
bis auf meine Nachttischlampe, die geht auf
1% an, sodass ich den Weg
vom Wohnzimmer ins Schlafzimmer auch finde.
Das ist auch eine coole
Möglichkeit, das zu machen. Ich habe eine Szene, die heißt
Last in Bed.
Das ist meine Nachttisch...
Alles ist aus, außer meiner Nachttischlampe geht auf...
Die linke geht auf...
Ich habe links und rechts eine Nachttischlampe, die ich separat steuern kann.
Die linke
geht auf minimal an,
weil das ist die Seite, auf der ich schlafe, damit ich
anders weg. Das ist klug.
Cool ist es,
wenn du, hast du schon
mit, ich bleib mal
bei dem Dashboard,
ich hab hier ein paar
Gauges für
Luftfeuchtigkeit und
Temperatursensoren, die ich im
Haus verteilt hab in jedem Zimmer. Fancy.
Die kriegst du
glaube ich für 15 Euro das Stück, das ist so
groß wie ein AirTag, kannst du an eine Wand kleben
und das über. Und was sprechen die?
Die sprechen
Zigbee. Bei mir ist alles
Zigbee. Aber da können wir nachher nochmal drüber
reden, was das unterscheidet, weil du hast es ja glaube ich relativ
anders gemacht als ich. Ich glaube, ja.
Aber es ist ein sehr diverses Setup bei mir.
Und dann habe ich hier quasi Gages
für die Temperatur in jedem Raum.
Unten drunter eine Kache mit der Luftfeuchtigkeit
und das ist eine Temperaturkurve.
Ihr könnt euch das in dem Screenshot
angucken, links auf der Seite.
Ich gebe jetzt hier private Daten über den Temperaturverlauf
in meiner Wohnung freis.
Das hier ist
in der Mobilansicht ganz unten.
Das ist einfach bloß diverse Integrationen, die regelmäßig geupdatet werden und ob sie up-to-date sind.
Und dann kann ich hier direkt drauf klicken und Update klicken.
Ah, okay.
Oder Insta klicken.
Und ansonsten habe ich hier eigentlich so eine Unterkachel für die meisten wichtigen Räume.
Das ist hier Wohnzimmer.
Äh, Quatsch, das ist Schlafzimmer.
Ich habe hier zum Beispiel Licht im Schlafzimmer an, das kann ich mal ausmachen.
Im Schlafzimmer kann ich auch dieses, das ist, man kann oben so einzelne Buttons,
so kleine Pillen machen
für bestimmte Szenen. Hier habe ich so eine bestimmte Szene
draufgelegt oder das ist dieses Last in Bed
oder der Ventilator, der ist normalerweise
im Schlafzimmer, aber jetzt steht er hier
neben meinem Fahrrad.
Und hier habe ich so ein bisschen historische Kurven
und das sind hier die Lichter in der
rechts oben sind Lichter
im Wohnzimmer.
Nice. Genau und hier habe ich mal rumgespielt.
Warum flackern diese Lampenslider?
Diese Slider hier sind eigentlich cool,
aber die sind jeweils auf diverse Lampen eingestellt.
Also hier hinter Colors sind alle meine Color-enableden Lampen drin.
Und ich glaube,
du hast hier einen Slider drin,
den ich einfach so rumdrehen kann.
Und das habe ich hier zum Beispiel für Office.
Da geht dann direkt auch die eine Stehlampel mit an,
die sonst nicht mit an ist.
Und ich glaube, diese Slider kommen nicht drauf klar,
wenn die Lampen diese Vereinen
unterschiedliche Werte eingestellt haben,
dann hopsen die zwischen dem Wert und dem einen.
Das ist ein Bug, den würde ich sehen.
Genau.
Ja, ich habe dann hier eine Kachel
nur für meine Heizkörper.
Sehr schön.
Und deren History, also eine Unterseite.
Eine für ein Netzwerk.
Hier ist das QR-Code von meinem Gäste-Wi-Fi
und es ist momentan an.
Und es gibt noch irgendeine Ausschaltung.
Das ist das Fritzbox Gäste-Wi-Fi
und das mache ich an sich nur an,
wenn ich entweder mit meinem Dienstlechner
von zu Hause arbeite oder wenn ich
Besuch habe. Und wenn ich das toggle, dann
geht dieses Geflacker an und aus.
Ah. So als Warning.
Genau. Ich kann aber auch
einzelne Geräte, hier zum Beispiel
die beiden
Amazon-Geräte im Haus kann ich
hier hart mit ausmachen. Sehr schön.
Also einfach diese Verbindung kappen. Genau.
Oder man kann auch, also hier hast
du ja genau diese
Upstream- oder Downstream-Visualisierung
von der Fritzbox, die du vorhin genannt hast.
Ich finde das wunderschön, dass die Fritzbox-Integration
diese Daten mit aufgreift und das Entity bereitstellt.
Das ist toll.
Also ich persönlich habe, mir ist noch kein guter Use-Case
dafür eingefallen, außer dass man
irgendeine Lampe auf irgendeinen Pegel
als einsteigt. So was möchte ich mal davon.
Also im Normal-Case ist das auch irrelevant,
aber es gibt ja tatsächlich Leute, die haben eine gemieterte
Verbindung zu Hause und hat einen Anstoß,
wo sie nur 100 GB im Monat verbrauchen können,
weil es nur über Mobilfunk geht oder so.
Und dafür wäre das natürlich unglaublich
praktisch, wenn du diese Daten gut zur Verfügung
hast. Was witzig ist, ist, dass
die Fritzbox eine Integration ist, die
für jedes mit dem Netzwerk verbundene Gerät
ein neues Device zu deinem Home Assistant
hinzufügt. Das heißt, du kannst
hier theoretisch für jedes
Gerät, was deiner Fritzbox bekannt ist, einen neuen
Eindruck machen und den Internetzugriff davon
an- und ausmachen. Ja, aber ich hätte das geliebt im
Studentenwohnheim damals, wo wir Traffic-Limitierung
hatten. Es gab auch Wege drumherum
und diese Wege habe ich auch sehr regig
genutzt. Ich habe gehört, die
Studentenwohnheim-Internetbetreiber sind schlauer geworden
und haben diese Wege durch...
Die haben auch mittlerweile die Traffic-Limitierung abgeschafft.
Das ist auch gegen die Vergangenheit,
aber damals gab es ein Traffic-Limit
offiziell und da gab es...
Ihr habt damals Software
geschrieben, es gab Leute, die haben sich ein Android-Widget gebaut,
ich hatte es einfach in meiner Mac-Menu-Bar
in meinen aktuellen Traffic-Verbrauch,
damit ich das im Auge halten kann.
Weil das Problem ist, wenn das Limit aufgebraucht war,
dann wurde deine Verbindung geschlossen.
Und dann konntest du auch diese Drumherum-Wege nicht mehr nutzen.
Dann war einfach dicht.
Und das ist bei mir, ich glaube, zwei oder dreimal passiert
in den paar Jahren, die ich da gewohnt habe.
Aber das war echt schmerzhaft.
Ich habe sowas noch für mein Mobiltelefon.
Es gibt eine iOS-App, die heißt Mobile Daten.
Und die bietet dir dieses Widget an,
was dir irgendwie mit einem Emoji, was grinst, visualisiert.
ob du genauso viel Daten noch über hast,
wie du noch Tage im Monat hast.
Du meinst 1 GB pro Tag oder was?
Ja, wenn du 31 GB hast,
also wenn du schon 10% deines Monats,
deines Guthabens verbraucht hast,
aber noch nicht 10% des Monats vorbei sind,
dann guckt der traurig.
Da bin ich sehr froh über meinen Tarif mit unendlich Daten.
Das ist seitdem das ein Ding ist,
ist es so befreiend,
weil du einfach nicht mehr darüber nachdenken musst.
Das ist einfach ein Ding der Vergangenheit.
Kannst du mir nachhören noch drauf.
um zurück zum Home Assistant zu kommen
ich hab hier noch
ich hab ein paar von diesen
Dashboards sind zum Spielen
wo ich einfach mal
es gibt ja wirklich sehr viele Widgets, die man hier
verbauen kann, ich wollte sie einfach mal ausprobieren, aber ich benutze
sie nicht wirklich aktiv
wo ich gerade diese Zeitleisten da sehe
das habe ich, was ich auch sehr cool
finde an Home Assistant, ist du kannst auch so
Conditional Cards auf dein
Dashboard packen und ich habe
Türsensoren an meiner
Balkontür
und am Badfenster
also das quasi
Du hast wahrscheinlich relativ viel Geld dafür in den letzten Monaten ausgegeben.
Die habe ich schon länger, die Dinger.
Ach, die sind auch mit HomeKit. Genau, die sind
von EVE und so, also HomeKit-kompatible Dinge
und die habe ich dann
die sind das
Frickeligste, was im Home Assistant drin ist.
Sachen, die du über HomeKit reinziehst. Genau, und die müssen
nämlich diese HomeKit-Integration nutzen
von Home Assistant und
verlieren auch häufig die Verbindung.
Also jeden Tag fallen die irgendwann raus
und die kriegen auch keine Verbindung mehr.
Mein einziger Fix bisher ist,
dass ich eine Home Assistant Automation am Laufen habe,
die schaut, ob diese Devices unreachable sind
und falls ja, rebootet er in Pi.
Und das dauert bloß ein paar Sekunden,
aber ich finde das super nervig
und mittlerweile denke ich gar nicht mehr drüber nach,
aber in Pi rebootet aktuell mindestens einmal am Tag wahrscheinlich,
damit diese Geräte wieder reachable sind.
Und das missfällt mir doch sehr.
Aber über diese Conditional Cards sehe ich auch diese Historie,
aber nur wenn sie offen sind.
und da kann ich so lange mein
Balkontür offen, das sehe ich seit wann sie schon offen ist
auf meinem Dashboard.
Also nur eine History anzeigen,
wenn ein Gerät gerade irgendwie an ist.
Wenn es in diesem Stad ist, genau, sonst interessiert mich das nicht.
Und das finde ich macht das Dashboard
auch sehr angenehm in der Optik.
Das stimmt.
Was ich hier mal ausprobiert habe, ist
Unteradressen. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wo genau ich das
eingestellt habe, aber ich glaube, ich habe eine
für Living Room
und ich glaube, wenn ich
hier... Was meinst du mit Unteradressen?
Also es gibt, in dieser Hauptansicht hast du oben diese Tabs mit Unterseiten.
Das sind so Unterdashboards.
Unterdashboards.
Es gibt noch andere, es gibt hier noch in der Sidebar, gibt es auch noch.
Das sind Dashboards.
Das sind Dashboards und Unterdashboards.
Okay, nennen wir es Unterdashboards.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie die Unterdashboards heißen, aber das links sind.
Auf deinem Hauptdashboard hast du Unterdashboards.
Ja.
Und dann gibt es welche, die haben die Eigenschaft, dass die Subpages sind.
Oder irgendeine Checkbox kann man da drin setzen.
ich such mal kurz raus, wie die heißen, die haben als Typ View, die haben dieses Subview an,
und sobald du das anmachst, ich mach's jetzt nicht, verschwinden die da oben wieder.
Es sei denn, du bist gerade in der Edit-Ansicht.
Und das hat den coolen Effekt, dass ich jetzt eine Subview habe, die heißt Living Room,
die ist dann erreichbar unter Slash Living Room, und wenn ich hier auf dieses Living Room Widget,
ich benutze es nicht, ich hab's bloß damit rumgespielt, deswegen ist es, glaube ich, hier hinterlegt,
kann ich hier draufklicken und dann geh ich in einen Subview namens Living Room rein,
Das geht dann quasi konditional auf.
Und dann kann ich hier wieder zurückgehen.
Was ist witzig.
Und dann habe ich überlegt,
dass ich mal einfach für jedes Zimmer so eine Unterseite mache,
die immer relativ gleich aussieht.
Also ich schiebe es mal ein bisschen zusammen,
dass du siehst, wie es auf dem Telefon aussieht.
Dass ich dann quasi...
Ach so, damit du einfacher navigieren kannst durch die...
Damit ich immer oben alle Lampen habe
und unten so die Heizungssteuerung und Szenen zum Beispiel.
Okay, so ein bisschen nach Relevanz.
Genau.
Und dann habe ich noch...
Das ist ein Conditioner hier unten. Das ist einfach ein Zurück-Button.
Weil ich nämlich
keinen Bock habe, wenn ich auf diesem
Subview bin, ist hier ganz oben links so ein Zurück-Knopf.
Du hast den zweiten Zurück-Knopf gebaut.
Ich hab mir den zweiten gemacht, der einfach unten.
Dann komm ich wieder zurück.
Warum nicht? Klar, kann man auch machen.
Genau. Also das sind so Sachen
von der Konfiguration und
es tut uns leid, lieber
Akronomisierbar-Hörer. Ich hoffe, ihr habt die ganze Zeit
auf diesen Screenshot geschaut.
Das war eine sehr visuelle Unterhaltung.
Aber noch zu einem anderen Feature, was ich benutze, was ziemlich cool ist, und zwar Events. Benutzt du Events?
Ja, das ist meine Lieblings-Automation. Das wäre genau das nächste Thema gewesen. Ich wollte dich nach deiner Lieblings-Automation fragen und dann wäre ich mit meiner gekommen.
Also meine eine Automation ist, dass wenn ich lausche auf den Zustand von meinem Guest-Wi-Fi und wenn es an ist, dann sende ich einen Alarm.
Und wir können uns da mal austauschen im Detail, müssen wir nicht on VR machen, aber ich habe dann immer ein Skript und einen gleichnamigen Event und dann ein On-Event als Automation. Einmal ein Skript, was den Event feuert und dann etwas, was passiert, wenn der Event gefeuert wird, damit ich das möglichst entkoppeln kann.
Das geht bestimmt schöner, aber es klingt jetzt komplizierter.
Aber ich habe zum Beispiel die Automation,
dass wenn ich an meinem,
ich habe so einen kleinen Lichtschalter-Fernbedienung,
an meinem Bett kleben, mit an, aus dem,
steuert ganz normal das Licht in meinem Schlafzimmer.
Außer zwischen 23 und 2 Uhr nachts.
Dann sendet der, oder beziehungsweise jedes Mal,
so, das ist das Skript,
Jedes Mal, wenn ich den Ausknopf drücke, wird ein Skript ausgeführt.
Und das Skript sagt, ist es zwischen 23 und 2 Uhr nachts?
Wenn ja, dann sendet den Event Last One in Bed oder sowas.
Oder Go to Sleep.
Und wenn dieses Event gefeuert wird, wird die Alles-Aus-Szene ausgelöst.
Und genau dasselbe habe ich ohne Zeitbedingungen an meinem Wohnungsausgang.
wenn ich da das Licht ausmache,
an dem Lichtschalter direkt an der Wohnungstür,
dann geht in der gesamten Wohnung das Licht aus
oder alles aus, was ausgehen soll.
Und das hat den Vorteil,
dass ich einfach mein Licht anlassen kann,
gehe, den Knopf drücke und alles Licht geht aus.
Das ist cool.
Und wenn ich im Bett bin und im Bett das Licht ausmache,
dann mache ich vorher auch nicht irgendwie in der Wohnung das Licht aus.
Ich lasse überall das Licht an, wenn ich ins Bett gehe
und dann vom Bett aus,
also unter der Bedingung,
dass ich in diesem Zeitraum ins Bett gehe,
Wenn ich dann im Bett das Licht ausmache,
dann geht auch in der Gesamte das Licht aus.
Das klingt sehr konvolut, aber ich verstehe, was du meinst.
Mir ging es einfach darum,
dass ich nicht 35 Schritte machen muss,
sondern ich gehe einfach ins Bett, mache das Licht aus
und überall geht das Licht aus.
Das ist jetzt das, wo ich dann schon wieder sagen würde,
das wäre jetzt cool, wenn da so eine Art Siri
oder so was dazwischen wäre, irgendwas,
was so ein bisschen Verhalten beobachtet
und dann schlaue Entscheidungen trifft,
so wie, hey, du machst jedes Mal um diese Uhrzeit
das gesamte Licht aus, von diesem Knopf aus.
Verlassen das so, so ein System das erkennt?
Nee, aber manchmal freue ich mich, wenn mir, was weiß ich,
wenn mir Siri automatisch irgendwelche Apps vorschlägt,
die ich immer zufällig genau in dem Moment benutze.
Oh, du hast gerade deine Kopfhörer verbunden
und stehst gerade draußen oder hast gerade die Wohnung verlassen.
Ja, du willst wahrscheinlich deine Podcast-App aufmachen.
Ja, oh ja, genau.
Es ist früh morgens und du bist zu Hause
und du möchtest jetzt bestimmt deine Fitness-App benutzen oder irgend so was.
Und in Home Assistant gibt es ja auch so ein Voice Assistant.
Das habe ich bisher noch nicht probiert.
Also ich habe gesehen, es ist existiert, aber hat mich nicht tangiert bisher.
Das Thema können wir vielleicht für ein anderes Mal noch aufheben.
Aber das sind so die Haupt-Automations, die ich benutze.
Also einfach bloß zum richtigen Zeitpunkt alle Lichter ausmachen.
Ich hatte auch mal zeitweise, dass wenn eine bestimmte Person diese Wohnung betreten hat,
dass dann irgendwie alle Lichter blitzen.
Aber das ging dann relativ schnell jedem auf den Sack.
Und dann habe ich es wieder ausgemacht.
Das braucht man nicht.
meine Lieblings Automation ist gar nicht mal so komplex in Home Assistant.
Sie läuft mehr auf meinem Handy.
Und zwar, wenn ich in der Früh aufstehe,
dann stehe ich selten direkt auf,
sondern meistens bleibe ich eine Weile liegen.
Das heißt nicht, dass ich eine Stunde noch im Bett liege,
würde ich auch gerne.
Aber ich bin jemand, der sehr gerne einfach im Bett liegt.
Du bist ein Snoozer.
Ich bin ein Snoozer.
Aber weil es einfach die schönste ist,
ich stelle mir meinen Wecker gerne super früh und snooze
dann einfach noch eine halbe Stunde. Weil es einfach viel
angenehmer ist, wenn du noch die warme Decke
und zwei Kuschelkatzen
da liegen bleiben kannst.
Und die Automation, die ich habe, ist
iOS hat ja diese Shortcuts-App.
Und die Shortcuts-App hat
diverse Automation-Hooks, wo du auch
auf bestimmte Events reagieren kannst.
Und das ist relativ gut mit der Home Assistant-App?
Das ist relativ geil,
vor allem auch, weil die Shortcuts-App
sehr coole Automation Trigger hat.
Unter anderem kannst du zum Beispiel auch,
da habe ich ein bisschen trollend auf dem Handy meiner Mom eingerichtet,
wenn jemand hustet,
ist ein Automation Trigger.
Das kann auf...
Stimmt, weil das diese Geräuscherkennung...
Die musst du nochmal extra enablen, die ist nicht per Default an,
aber die kannst du enablen und dann kannst du
darauf reagieren, dass die Klingel,
dass deine Haustürklingel zum Beispiel,
so im Sinne von, du hast,
du bist hörmäßig eingeschränkt
und du möchtest zum Beispiel
dir eine Notification
senden lassen oder dein Handy
sagt dir Bescheid, wenn die Tür klingelt.
Ich kann nicht sagen Bescheid, weil das vielleicht in dieselbe Nerbe schlägt,
aber prinzipiell kannst du da alles dranhängen an Logik,
wenn die Tür klingelt betätigt wird oder
ein Rauchmelder losgeht oder ein Hund bellt
oder ein Kind schreit und das
ist schon mal großartig und da habe ich bei meiner
Mama mir die eingestellt, wenn jemand
hustet, kommt so eine Stimme aus dem Handy
und sagt Siri einfach, oh oh oh,
ich hoffe nicht schon wieder in die Quarantäne.
Oder wenn sie sich mit dem
Auto verbindet, geht ein Timer los mit
5 Minuten und dann sagt das Handy
nicht so schnell, Andrea.
Oh Mann. Finde ich sehr witzig. Aber was ich
bei mir eingerichtet habe, ist, du kannst als Automation
Trigger den
Snooze-Event deines Weckers nutzen.
Das heißt, wenn du
Snooze drückst,
was ich mache, mein Handy, mein Handy schaut
erstmal selbstständig, ob es in meinem Heim-Wi-Fi
ist, sprich, ob ich zu Hause bin.
Und falls ja, das habe ich nochmal als
Self-Grab mit rein, dass es nervig ist.
Man muss das immer aufs Telefon, diese Automation-Trigger.
Es gibt auch bessere Wege dafür, aber kannst du.
Und für manche Sachen musst du es leider.
Aber es geht.
Die UI dafür ist nicht gut.
Und es ist sehr frickelig, weil du sehr viel machen musst.
Aber die ist halt auch sehr komplex.
Und dafür aber auch sehr mächtig.
Jedenfalls schaut mein Handy erst, ob es im Heimwifi ist.
Und falls ja, startet es.
Das ist immer die erste Bedingung.
Und dann Uhrzeit checken?
Nee, nee, Uhrzeit brauche ich keine Checks.
Wenn ich den Wecker gesnuzzt habe, läuft meine Favoriten-Playlist auf Apple Music los.
Und, das habe ich schon längere Zeit genutzt,
aber was ich jetzt sehr cool finde,
was mir Home Assistant mit ermöglicht,
ist, ich schicke dank der Shortcuts Integration von Home Assistant ein Event an Home Assistant.
Und diesen Event nutze ich, um einmalseits erstmal einen Timer zu starten.
Fünf Minuten passiert erstmal gar nichts.
Und nach fünf Minuten geht meine Nachttischlampe auf ein Prozent Helligkeit an
und fährt dann über einen Zeitraum von 15 Minuten auf 50 Prozent hoch.
Und 50 Prozent ist die schon arg hell.
Aber das Geile ist, es ist nicht instant hell,
weil ich bin ja zu dem Zeitpunkt leicht munter und drücke auf Snooze.
Aber dann kann ich liegen bleiben und fünf Minuten später geht einfach das Licht an
und dann werde ich so wirklich wach,
weil das Licht hell genug ist.
Und das finde ich eine so unglaublich mächtige Sache,
die ich mir durch das Zusammenspiel
von multipler Hardware da ermögliche.
Die einzige Bedingung ist,
dass ich nicht schläfrig genug bin,
nicht den Snooze-Button,
sondern den Schließen-Button auf dem Wecker zu drücken.
Und damit fällt das Ganze flach,
weil der Wecker einfach aus ist dann
und ich potenziell einfach wieder einschlafe.
Aber ich bin dann geistesgegenwärtig genug,
den Snooze-Button zu erwischen.
Und dann freut es mich auch jeden Morgen wieder aufs Neue,
wie cool diese Automation ist.
Das finde ich sehr, sehr cool.
Das mit dem Licht, was du gerade gemeint hast,
ist so ein Use Case, den ich auch gerne wollte.
Es gibt ja diese Sonnenaufgangschlammen und so was.
Ich wollte aber nicht extra so ein Ding.
Ich habe ja schon smarte Lampen zu Hause.
Und so was als Skript zu bauen in Home Assistant,
ist relativ nervig.
Ja.
Und es gibt, wenn man unter diese,
ich gehe mal kurz hier unter Settings
und dann gibt es
den Punkt Automations and Scenes.
Warum liegen die Automationen alle in Settings?
Das kostet mich am meisten an, dass du wieder in die Settings
gehen musst. Und unter Automations and Scenes
gibt es Automations, Scenes,
Scripts
und
Blueprints.
Und Blueprints, da gibt es irgendeine
Discover-Seite, wo man sich
welche runterladen kann und da habe ich mir
Wake-up-Alarm-with-Sunrise-Effekt.
Das sind einfach so
vorgefertigte Sachen, die Leute gepasst haben.
Das sind vorgefertigte Sachen und das sieht auch ziemlich cool aus,
wenn man sich die Flow-Visualisierung...
Was macht das so?
Und das macht einfach nur, dass man mit bestimmten
Eingaben einem bestimmten Gerät
sagen kann, du sollst jetzt bitte Sunrise machen
und dann langsam hell werden.
Ich weiß nicht, wie du deiner Lampe
gesagt hast, dass sie langsam heller werden soll,
aber du sagst wahrscheinlich, machst einen Loop
und sagst, zähle, mach Pause
und werde ein Stück heller und mache Pause.
Das ist so viel einfacher. Ich habe einfach gesagt,
also Home Assistant bringt das direkt mit.
Ich kann eine Brightness Value angeben, wo ich hin möchte
und dann eine Transition über 900 Sekunden.
Und das war es.
Vielleicht ging das noch nicht lang.
Das ist direkt eine Action in dieser Automation.
Einfach nur, werde so hell
und brauche so lang. Tada, das war es.
Wow. Deshalb wollte ich diese Sendung
mit dir machen.
Vielleicht ging das noch nicht immer.
Ich habe das nämlich dreimal benutzt, diesen Blueprint,
und habe dann gemerkt, dass er irgendwie hakelig ist
ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was es war und ich hab ihn seitdem schon eine Weile
nicht mehr benutzt, aber das ist eine Sache,
die ich gerne hätte, dass ich
und genau das, was du gerade beschrieben hast,
werde ich mir jetzt nachbauen. Das nervigste
ist der
der iOS-Anteil
davon, das zu klickern.
Aber der Teil läuft auch sehr zuverlässig.
Es gibt auch Sachen, die
ich immer noch mit
HomeKit mache, also HomeKit
hab ich eigentlich nicht wirklich verwendet,
aber du kannst ja,
es gibt die HomeKit-Integration, sodass du
selbst wenn du vorher kein HomeKit hattest,
möchtest du zum Beispiel eine Siri-Integration
auf deinem Telefon haben.
Und dann habe ich einfach so eine HomeKit-Freigabe gemacht,
wo der Home Assistant alle Geräte,
die er eigentlich verwaltet,
dann via HomeKit freigibt.
Und dadurch kann ich alle Geräte auch
per HomeKit theoretisch steuern.
Was absolut
nervig ist, weil die ab und zu mal verschwinden
und dann nicht mehr da sind.
Die HomeKit-Integration von Home Assistant
ist wirklich mit Abstand das
unzuverlässigste.
ich weiß nicht, ob das an HomeKit oder an Home Assistant
liegt, keine Ahnung, aber das ist so, das benutze ich
hauptsächlich, um sagen zu können, hey Siri,
activate the fan.
Und dann geht der Ventilator an.
Ein Skript, was ich
gemacht habe, das habe ich häufig auch, weil der
Ventilator im Sommer in meinem Schlafzimmer steht,
ich habe ein Skript, das heißt
Fan for Ten.
Was? Wenn ich das auslöse,
geht der Ventilator an und nach 10 Minuten wieder aus.
Fan for Ten, okay.
Sehr schön.
Hast du auch nur das Namens wegen angelegt?
Nee, nee.
Ja, ich hab immer, du liegst
im Bett und es ist warm und du machst dir ein bisschen
diese Brise an, aber du willst es nicht, dass die die ganze
Nacht läuft und deswegen ist es
lang genug an, dass ich dabei einschlafen kann
und dann geht es wieder aus. Das ist ganz gut.
Was ich noch sehr cool finde, ist die ganze
Energy Integration von Home Assistant.
Die haben da so ein extra Energy Usage Panel,
was halt so extra drauf ausgelegt ist,
wie viel Strom holst
du dir aus dem Grid oder speist du wieder ein
durch irgendwelche... Benutzt du das?
Ich habe noch kein Balkonkraftwerk,
das wäre noch mein To-Do gewesen eigentlich für letztes Jahr.
Jetzt wird es wahrscheinlich für dieses Jahr was werden.
Das ist so ein schöner, fetter Button
hier in dieser Ansicht, den ich nicht ausmachen kann.
Ja, das finde ich ein bisschen
nervig. Es wirkt fast so, als ob sie Werbung für irgendwas
machen. Aber so ist es nicht.
Aber du kannst auf jeden Fall auch
andere Geräte, die einfach nur verbrauchen, reinhängen.
Und somit sehe ich meine ganzen Verbraucher,
die an Steckdosen
hängen, die Strom
messen können. Und ich habe noch so ein extra Panel,
wo ich das auch nochmal extra sehe. Aber ich habe
Ich habe ein paar Verbraucher zu Hause, wo ich das tatsächlich mit messe.
Das ist einmal mein 3D-Drucker, das ist einmal mein Rechner mit der Standrechner
und das ist einmal mein Fernseher.
Die hängen an irgendwelchen bestimmten Steckdosen?
Die hängen an so Strommesse-Steckdosen.
Die sind Homekit-Steckdosen.
Witzigerweise habe ich da zwei unterschiedliche Generationen,
die ich herausgefunden habe.
Die einen sprechen Matter, die anderen nicht.
Und diejenigen, die Matter sprechen, waren sehr, sehr einfach zu integrieren.
Die anderen sprechen nur...
Thread.
Nee, Thread ist...
Als ich mich schlau gemacht hatte, bei der Integration habe ich es verstanden.
Ich glaube, du sprichst Third Over Matter oder irgendwie so.
Als du mir das gesagt hast, das eine ist ein Subprotokoll vom anderen,
aber verstanden habe ich es auch nicht.
Ja, aber es gibt noch diese alte Möglichkeit, wie die bei HomeKit mit drin hängen.
Und die Sachen können nur mit einer Bridge verbunden sein,
was super nervig für die Integration ist, weil sich HomeKit versucht,
die immer zu claimen dann.
Und Thread ist irgendwie so ein Mesh-Netzwerk.
Und das Geile, wenn die Matter sprechen, dann sagst du einfach, das ist da.
HomeKit sieht das, Home Assistant sieht das, beide sprechen das Ding an
und die sind rock solid. Und das ist richtig geil.
Ich bin fast verleitet, mir die einfach, die, die das nicht sprechen,
rauszuschmeißen und mir neue zu kaufen.
Also dann können wir ja mal jetzt, und das ist
der Zeitpunkt, wo ich in
dieser App hier mal kurz so ein M setze.
Jetzt können wir uns mal tatsächlich über
Protokolle unterhalten, jetzt über den friedlichen
Teil, weil
du hast gerade gesagt, das ist praktisch auf einem Raspberry Pi,
weil der Bluetooth schon mitbringt.
Das war mir wichtig. Die Art und Weise. Ich glaube doch,
dass das Aranet, sprich Bluetooth, das war genau
das Problem, was ich hatte. Ich glaube,
das ist darüber eingebunden. Also wie verbindet
man, für jemanden, der noch nie
mit Home Assistant was gemacht hat oder selbst für Leute
wie mich, die was mit Home Assistant machen und
dieses gesamte Spektrum
noch nicht kennen. Es gibt zigtausend Möglichkeiten.
Es gibt zigtausend Möglichkeiten. Also Home Assistant läuft
auf einem Raspberry Pi.
Es ist ein vollständiger Computer
mit einem Web-Interface
und zum Beispiel die Integration
der Fritzbox funktioniert über REST API.
Genau, also die Fritzbox kann WLAN,
weil HH ist ja ein Router. Genau, was
über die REST API
auch funktioniert.
Ich kann mal zum Spaß, warte,
wo ist das? Unter Devices
und Services gibt es Integrations.
Was ich auch als Integration habe,
ist, hier ist
ein Gerät drin, ist
meine Stereoanlage.
Damit kann ich nämlich die
anmachen, oder ich weiß nicht, ob ich sie anmache, doch, jetzt geht sie gerade
an, ich kann Play drücken und die Lautstärke
über meine Home Assistant steuern.
Und
ich habe mir noch keine
Automation
dafür gebaut, aber
die Stereoanlage kann nun
wiederum über, wie heißt das, DLNA
auf meinen
NAS zu greifen und
ich kann theoretisch, ich hatte schon kurz angefangen
das zu bauen und das war mir dann zu nervig,
ich kannte mir eine
Automation bauen, die hab ich angefangen, die heißt
Christmas Mood,
wo du sagen kannst, mach da bestimmte
Lichtszene an und dann spiel
von meinem NAS aus einem bestimmten Ordner
die Musik auf der Stereo-Lager.
Großartig, das gefällt mir.
Für mich reicht die
Möglichkeit, dass es, die Tatsache,
dass es existiert und ich freue mich daran, dass ich es machen könnte.
Ich hatte dann keine Geduld, es tatsächlich
zu implementieren.
Und das sind so Integrationen, die über das lokale
Netzwerk funktionieren und dann gibt es natürlich auch
Integrationen mit Public Services, wie zum Beispiel
dieser Wetterservice, der drin ist, der einfach bloß
REST API abfragt.
Eine meiner Integrationen ist der Müllkalender
von Dresden und da habe ich mal auf meinem Dashboard
einfach, wann welcher Müll geleert wird.
Als über diese Kalenderintegration.
Genau und habe dann aber zusätzlich auf meinem Dashboard
eben hier so, Papier wird in vier Tagen geleert.
Gelber Sack in neun Tagen. Das werde ich mir
von dir klauen. Und das ist halt auch sehr praktisch,
weil ich dann weiß, wann die Tonne leer ist. Weißt du, was wir machen können?
Wir können unsere Konfigurations-Jammels
mal exporten und
austauschen untereinander. Ja,
ich werde vorher mal schauen müssen, dass da nichts
Weirdes drinsteht, weil ich glaube, ich habe da vielleicht
ein paar Credentials gehartcoded drin. Wo du mir
vorhin gesagt hast, dass dein neuer
Lieblings-Editor VS Code ist, hast du die
VS Code-Integration installiert? Nein.
Es gibt, pass auf. Ich habe einfach nur die lame
File Editor Integration, weil wir die...
Es gibt die File Editor Integration,
die geht, aber nicht schön ist.
Und es gibt die Studio Code Server
Integration, womit du
auf alle Dateien auf deinem
Home Assistant zugreifen kannst.
Und es ist einfach mein fucking VS Code.
Ich hätte Angst, dass das zu ressourcenlastig ist,
wenn das jemand im Hintergrund läuft.
Das läuft ja vornehmlich
im Browser.
Stimmt eigentlich, ja.
Aber ich kann hier quasi alles
innerhalb von diesem VS Code,
was in meinem Home Assistant installiert ist, habe ich natürlich auch
Extensions installiert. Das heißt, ich habe
die Vim-Extension
im VS Code-Plugin
in meinem Home Assistant drauf.
Sehr schön. Das ist cool.
Genau.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich über Protokolle reden,
aber ich habe ja die Integrations als
als
Einstiegspunkt davon benutzt.
Was bereits standardmäßig
an ist, ist ein iBeacon-Tracker,
weil das Gerät Bluetooth kann. Benutzt du das?
Ja.
Da habe ich keinerlei Use Case für.
Man könnte es, meine Überlegung war, dass das eventuell benutzt werden könnte, um zu checken, ist dein Telefon in der Nähe oder nicht?
Ja, aber übers Netzwerk hast du eine viel zuverlässigere Aussage darüber, ob du zu Hause bist.
Und mehr als ob ich zu Hause bin, wüsste ich nicht, was ich darüber abbilden sollte.
Ich glaube, du würdest darüber abbilden, in welchem Raum bist du gerade.
Wenn du das so feingranular machen kannst, aber dafür lebe ich einfach nicht in groß genügend Anwesen,
dass das einen Unterschied macht.
Was ich mal versucht hatte zu bauen,
ich habe bei mir so einen Knopf,
will ich nicht sagen,
mehr so ein elektronischer kleiner Finger
neben meiner Gegensprechanlage
für die Haustür kleben
und die kann auslösen
und kann den Türöffnungsknopf betätigen,
sodass ich meine Haustür aufmachen kann.
Und ich dachte mir,
irgendwie kriege ich es vielleicht automatisiert,
aber wenn ich zu Hause ankomme,
das ausgelöst wird.
Wenn du vor der Tür stehst,
die von alleine angeht, dass du den Schlüssel nicht brauchst.
Genau, dieses Feingranulare, ich bin
unten vor der Tür, kriege ich nicht gebacken.
Und aktuell habe ich es so am Laufen,
dass ich die App von dem Hersteller,
dieses Knopfes, die auch eine Apple Watch App hat,
ist angenehmer zu nutzen,
wenn ich unten gerade mit dem Fahrrad vor der Tür stehe,
als mein Schlüssel rauszukramen, die mir die Tür aufmacht.
Musst du mit dem Schlüssel durch die Haustür,
bevor du an die Briefkästen kommst?
Die Briefkästen sind innen, ja.
Weißt du, wie der Postbote bei dir ins Haus kommt?
Das habe ich mich schon immer gefragt.
In meiner alten Wohnung hatten die einen Extraschlüssel.
So ein fancy, so ein rundes Ding.
Kennst du alle deine Nachbarn in deinem Haus?
Ja.
Dann schau mal auf dein Klingelschild, ob da irgendwelche absurden Namen ganz oben stehen.
Das habe ich auch schon mal gehört, dass es darüber ist.
Aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass die Postbotinnen bei uns haben einen Schlüssel.
Die haben so einen fetten Schlüsselbund.
Ich kenne Leute, da gibt es einen bestimmten Namen auf der Klingel.
Wenn du da drauf drückst, geht sofort die Tür auf.
Manchmal gibt es auch so eine explizite Post, steht da auch mit dran.
Das gibt es ja auch in manchen Häusern.
Ja, also es gibt die verschiedensten Lösungen für.
Aber ich würde das gerne, also wir haben auch so ein Tor quasi in unserer Haustür.
Unsere Haustür ist einerseits so eine kleine Tür eingelassen in das Tor.
Und das ganze Tor kannst du auch aufmachen mit so einer Fernbedienung, weil dahinter im Haus Parkplätze sind.
Und ich wollte schon immer diese Fernbedienung, die habe ich gerade nicht.
Aber wenn ich sie wieder habe, weil ich meinen Nachbarn verliehen habe seit ein paar Monaten,
dann werde ich hier mit dem Flipper Zero mal die Codes rausscannen müssen und schauen, ob ich das irgendwie mal integriert bekomme.
weil ich würde gerne, wenn ich mit dem Fahrrad ankomme,
auch meinetwegen eine Minute vorher schon das Tor öffnen
und dann fahre ich durch einfach
und dann, weil die Fahrradparkplätze auch hinten sind.
Das ist der Traum.
Wo mir das mit dem Flipper Zero,
ich möchte wirklich auf die Protokolle zu sprechen kommen,
aber der haupt ausschlaggebende Punkt für mich,
den Home Assistant mit dem dazugehörigen Protokoll zu holen,
war, ich hatte vorher diese banalen Funksteckdosen mit an und aus,
wo du auf einer Fernbedienung mit vier Kanälen jeweils vier Knöpfe
nur mit an und aus vergeben kannst.
Und das hatte vorher für mich ausgereicht,
um bei mir das Licht anzumachen und auszumachen.
Und da hatte ich irgendwann kurzzeitig Angst,
dass ich vielleicht irgendwie ausspioniert werde.
Denn manchmal bin ich nach Hause gekommen
und das Licht in meinem Schlafzimmer war an.
Und dann habe ich überlegt,
Ich so als Security-Aware-Mensch habe mir gedacht, okay, wenn ich jetzt checken wollen würde, ob jemand im Urlaub ist, dann würde ich mit so einer Fernbedienung das Licht anmachen und schauen, ob es nach zwei Tagen immer noch an ist.
Wenn es nach zwei Tagen noch an ist, ist die Person wahrscheinlich länger Zeit nicht zu Hause.
Das ist sehr glücklich.
Ja.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ich muss das loswerden.
Und das habe ich eine Weile vor mir hergeschoben und irgendwann lag ich morgens im Bett an einem Montagmorgen
und da werde ich frühmorgens immer geweckt von der Müllabfuhr, die besonders laut rumrumpelt vor der Tür.
Und genau in dem Moment, wo die Müllabfuhr vor der Tür stand, ist bei mir mein rechtes Schlafzimmerlicht angegangen.
Weil sie wahrscheinlich mit irgendwas, entweder fahren sie hinten diesen Heber hoch und runter.
Funk von vorn? Über irgendein Standard-Funk-Dings,
was doof genug ist,
dass es zufällig auch meine
Nachttischlampe mit ankommt.
Das ist irgendein sub-Ger-Herz-Ding, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, was da gesendet wird. Das ist der Bereich,
wo ich Informatiker bin,
wo für mich Strom binär entweder an oder aus ist.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz,
also an meinem Home Assistant, um jetzt endlich
zu diesem Punkt zu kommen,
hängt ein
ZigBidongle.
Das heißt, alle meine
Lampen, meine Glühbirnen sind
vornehmlich Trattfree
oder Hue
oder Inner, das ist so ein
holländischer Hersteller, die machen auch
ziemlich coole, bezahlbare Lampen.
Und die sprechen alle
Zigbee und manche von den
Hue-Geräten auch zusätzlich Bluetooth.
Wenn man so eine Hue-Bridge hat, was ja quasi
dasselbe ist, Hue-Bit ist ja eine
Alternative zu Home Assistant,
dann hat man so eine
Hue-Bridge stehen, die spricht mit fast
Geräten.
Jetzt
blicken gerade alle Lampen hier.
Völlig wörend im Gefühl.
Irgendwas hat auf der Fritzbox
ein Netzwerkevent ausgelöst.
Entweder ist jetzt ein Gerät angegangen oder ausgegangen
oder es hat irgendein Update gemacht.
Das passiert, wenn das Gästennetzwerk
an ist. Vielleicht ist dein Laptop eingeschlafen oder
angegangen. Keine Ahnung. Anyway.
Hue-Lampen sind
über Zigbee, manchmal auch über Bluetooth
verbunden und wenn du dir Hue-Lampen kaufen
willst, dann musst du wirklich auf
auf Amazon nachgucken, ist das eine,
die auch Zigbee kann oder manche können nur
Bluetooth. Das Geile an Zigbee ist ja,
dass es so viel schneller
ist als Bluetooth.
Bluetooth muss ja meistens irgendwie die Verbindung
wieder erstmal aktivieren und dann dauert das
bis du, keine Ahnung, 10 Sekunden,
bis du dann ein Signal drüber bekommst.
Genau, also bei Zigbee,
naja, wenn ich eine Szene anmache, dann sind auch
manche Lampen erst 3 Sekunden nach den,
also das dauert auch manchmal 3 Sekunden,
bis alle Lampen sich umgeschalten haben.
Der richtig geile Scheiß ist Matter.
Naja, das wird aber auch daran liegen, dass der Home Assistant
oder dass dieser Funkstaat...
Ja, ich weiß nicht wie.
Er muss wahrscheinlich jedem Gerät einzeln sagen, was er machen muss.
Und das kann er nicht gleichzeitig. Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Zigbee ist schön,
aber was ich bei mir dran stecken habe, ist ein
Kombi 2 von Dresden Electronics.
Das ist immer so geil, dass diese Firma existiert.
Dresden Electronics. Und die sitzen in Dresden
und stellen dieses Zeugs her.
Es gibt sogar seit ein paar Wochen
erst den Kombi 3.
Und den kann man in Home Assistant
integrieren, über, habe ich auch erst vor kurzem gelernt,
über zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder über das
D-Cons, die D-Cons-Integration, oder
über eine Home Assistant eigene
war es C-Wave oder
irgendeine Zigbee-Integration,
die, ähm...
War C-Wave auch Zigbee oder war es
irgendein Zigbee-Konkurrenz-Ding?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Oder C-Pi. Es gibt zumindest
noch eine weitere, wenn du auf die
Conbee-Webseite gehst, das kann ich mal
ganz kurz machen, dann siehst du, ähm...
Combi
siehst du unter
nicht unter Compatibility,
aber unter
Software, glaube ich.
Hier genau.
Die Integration in den Home Assistant
und dann über was es geht.
Ich packe da mal einen Link in die Show Notes.
Und das hat
aber bei mir den doofen Effekt.
Ich habe mich für die Combi-Integration entschieden
und das ist ja auch, wenn du da einmal drin bist,
hast du da
30 Glühbirnen und
Lichtschalter und Steckdosen
integriert und man wechselt
diese Integration nicht. Da verbringt
man einen halben Tag damit, seine gesamte Wohnung neu
einzurichten.
Und das
hat bei mir
die Ansicht,
ich habe hier diese Decon-Integration
und da kann ich, wenn ich da drauf
gehe, geht die Zigbee-Network bei
Dresden Elektronik-Sub-App auf.
Die läuft auf dem Stick in einem
Docker-Container
und ich kann da in zwei
Integrationen reingehen. Entweder die Foscon
Ansicht, was eine weitere Web-App ist,
wo ich mich dann nochmal ganz kurz authentifizieren
muss mit einem Passwort
und jetzt habe ich eine
App, die so ähnlich aussieht wie
Home Assistant, die da drin läuft,
die allerdings alle Geräte,
die da drin sind, sind für
Home Assistant für die Integration sichtbar.
Ah, okay. Das ist ein Interface
dafür hier. Das ist ein Interface, aber es hat
den witzigen Charme, dass ich in dieser
App-Szenen zusammen
klickern kann, was ein bisschen schöner ist,
die dann nach außen für Home Assistant
als importierte Szenen sichtbar sind.
Und die kann ich dann anderen ausmachen.
Witzig.
Es ist allerdings doppelt gemoppelt.
Es ist ein bisschen unschön. Deswegen hatte ich schon mal
überlegt, ob ich das in irgendwas wechsle.
Aber
jetzt bin ich einmal hier eingebaut und
das geht.
Es gibt für Zigbee noch eine andere Integration, aber
so läuft es momentan.
Man könnte allerdings auch seine
Aber ich hatte neulich überlegt, diese Hue-Lampen können bestimmte Effekte an und aus machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das benutzt, aber zum Beispiel, man kann so einer Lampe sagen...
Die sind alle scheiße. Ich mag die gar nicht.
Also die können so Kerzen flackern.
Kerzen flackern, Lagerfeuer oder Fireplace-Animation oder sowas.
Also es ist wahrscheinlich ganz cool, wenn du es auch dementsprechend nutzt.
Also keine Ahnung, so eine Lampe hinter einer Couch oder irgendwo, wo sie halt effektvoll verbaut ist.
Aber wenn man eine Deckenlampe wie eine Kerze flackern lässt, finde ich...
Ansicht von dieser Lampe dort gehe.
Das ist eine Stehlampe.
Und die kann ich hell und dunkel machen und da kann ich hier
natürlich mit diesem UI in Home Assistant
die Farbe ändern.
So. Und
irgendwelche vorgespeicherten Farben anmachen und es gibt
hier unten Effekt.
Und unter Effekt gibt es einen Effekt,
der heißt Color Lobe und jetzt geht er einfach
total nervig
einmal durch, also hier
einmal auf diesem Color Wheel im Kreis.
Finde ich auch ganz nett.
Ist nett. Ist auch nett, wenn du das
auf allen Lampen anmachst,
aber du kannst es nicht.
Du kannst jetzt nicht hier hingehen.
Colors ist eine Gruppe
mit allen Lichtern, wo ich jetzt auf allen
Lichtern
die Farbe gleich einstellen kann. Jetzt werden alle
meine Lichter lila.
Aber hier gibt es auch
Color Loop. Passiert nichts.
Das geht nur, wenn du das auf einer Lampe spezial machen kannst.
Und was ist hier nicht drin?
Candlelight oder Fireplace.
Und das wäre manchmal geil, wenn ich hier jeder Lampe
diesen Candlelight-Effekt geben würde.
Das geht leider nicht. Dafür kann ich,
und jetzt wird's geil,
Screenshots folgen.
Wenn ich in dieser Decon-Integration gehe,
ich weiß nicht,
es gibt die Foscon
Web-App, die ich dir gerade gezeigt habe,
und es gibt noch die Decon-Application
through VNC.
Oh Gott.
Wenn ich da drauf klicke,
geht hier drin irgendwie,
ich glaube, das ist XFCE
oder LXF,
so ein alter Linux-Desktop auf, über
VNC mit so einer schönen GTK-Anwendung.
Oh, ich liebe es.
Innerhalb von dem Home Assistant, was wie gesagt
eine Web-Anwendung ist, ja. Also das kann ich
auch auf meinem Tablet aufmachen.
Und diese Anwendung, warte mal, die läuft auf diesem
Stick immer noch? Die läuft immer noch auf diesem
Stick? Das Geile ist ja,
diesen Stick sollst du auch einfach an deinen Laptop
ranstecken können und dann geht das
darüber. Und dann sprichst du
VNC over USB.
Ja.
Es ist weird. Aber hier
sind alle Funktionen von den Geräten
verfügbar. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt bei dieser...
Ich hoffe,
Henrik vergisst den Screen-Shot.
Diese Anwendung sieht so höllisch kompliziert.
Wie so ein uralter Node-Editor.
Naja, genau. Die sind aus irgendeinem
Grund sind die alle miteinander verbunden. Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Und die Lightbar habe ich hier aufgefaltet.
Und hier gibt es einen Unterpunkt.
Die haben einfach hart gecodet.
Jedes Signal, von dem sie wissen, was man an diese Geräte
senden kann. Hinter irgendwas.
Und hier gibt es eine Gruppe mit dem Präfix
FC03.
das sind die Hue-Effekts und wenn ich da draufklicke, dann geht hier, ich glaube hier, dann geht hier dieser Effekt auf und dann kann ich sagen, hier kann ich tatsächlich Candle und Fireplace und Sunrise und Sparkle, die leider nicht ganz funktionieren, ausweilen.
Und wenn ich nicht vergesse, den Enable-Button,
die Checkbox auch noch zu setzen,
dann sende ich jetzt das Kommando 0x0021
an die Lightbar und du siehst, die flackert da hinten
so ein bisschen hinter meinem Sofa.
In der Tat.
Bist du völlig intuitiv und einfach?
Es ist herrlich.
Es ist absolut unbenutzbar.
Aber es ist keinerlei Möglichkeit,
in den Home Assistant rein exportiert,
wie ich das steuern kann.
Deswegen hätte ich Interesse daran,
diese Sachen irgendwie vielleicht durch eine andere Integration
in dieses Dresden-Elektronik-Dongelchen durchzuschleifen.
Aber wenn ich die GitHub-Issues richtig lese,
ist diese Funktionalität einfach nicht durchgereicht.
Okay.
Also man merkt,
da steckt unglaubliche Möglichkeiten an Komplexität mit drin.
Aber Home Assistant ermöglicht Dinge auch sehr einfach.
Ja, theoretisch müsste ich ja diesen Zigbee-Dongel nicht benutzen.
Ich könnte auch alle Geräte mit einer HueBridge verbinden,
die ich zufällig auch besitze, aber nicht auch noch haben will.
Weil die HueBridge kannst du dann auch bloß nicht mit HomeKit verbinden.
Da brauchst du dann wieder einen...
Also bei meinen Eltern hatte ich eine HueBridge eine Zeit lang laufen.
Und damit mein Vater dann über Siri oder irgendwas Licht an und aus machen kann,
was wir nie zu Ende gebaut haben,
habe ich noch einen Raspberry Pi mit einem
mit einem Hue Bridge
Image
laufen.
Du hast eine virtuelle Hue Bridge am Laufen gehabt.
Nee, Hue Bridge, hieß es
Hue Bridge, es gibt halt noch sowas wie Home Assistant.
Ach, Home Bridge.
Home Bridge.
Womit du Sachen einfach bloß nach HomeKit schleifst.
Das ist kein Home Assistant.
Ja, okay, das war ein extra Ding.
Aber du kannst auch, ich könnte auch alle Geräte mit der
Hue Bridge verbinden und dann die Hue Bridge
per Hue-Integration
mit Home Assistant verbinden.
Aber die Hue Bridge spricht doch
nativ, also Home Assistant,
beziehungsweise auch HomeKit. Da brauchst du weder
Home Bridge noch irgendwas Frickeliges.
Was meinst du mit die Hue Bridge spricht nativ Home Assistant?
Die Hue Bridge habe ich schon eine Weile
die Hue Bridge
habe ich schon eine Weile für meine Deckenlampen,
die Philips Hue sind.
Und die hängen immer, also ohne
irgendwas Frickeliges in HomeKit direkt drin.
Genau, das könnte ich auch machen.
Oder ich habe den Home Assistant eingeschaltet
das allererste, was HomeKit gesagt hat.
Du, ich sehe Hue Devices. Willst du die integrieren?
Okay, sind jetzt drin. Um diesen mitunter das
Stabilste, was du ansprechen kannst.
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich einfach das machen sollen.
Mittlerweile,
ich hatte eine Trattfree Bridge, ich habe eine Hue Bridge,
ich habe diesen Donkel.
Du hast das heterogenste
Setup, was nur möglich ist.
Ich würde den ganzen Scheiß ja nicht gleichzeitig betreiben.
Ich habe mir gedacht, ich entscheide mich
für die Open-Source-Variante
und dementsprechend habe ich diesen
und unterstütze regionale
regionale Produkte.
Und deswegen benutze ich
den Kombi 2 von
Dresden Elektronik, aber
vielleicht war es einfacher gewesen, die
Hubbridge irgendwie gerade schauen,
mit dem Haushestand zu finden.
Dann könnte ich nämlich die coolen Effekte
Diese Effekte braucht keine Sau.
Ich finde die super nervig. Doch!
Doch!
Für eine Halloween-Party haben wir es gehabt.
Und dann machst du Deko.
Diese Effekte braucht keine Sau an 364 Tagen.
äh, und ich hab noch mehr
Use Cases, wir haben nämlich vorhin,
pass auf, jetzt schließt sich der Kreis,
eine
Automation, die ich gerne noch bauen möchte,
und vielleicht machen wir das zusammen
als Bastelprojekt, ist
eine Minecraft-Integration.
Okay. Und zwar
möchte ich, dass das Licht in
meiner Wohnung
der Tageszeit in Minecraft
entspricht.
Und wenn ich in ein Haus gehe, wo
Kerzen oder Torches
flackern, dann möchte ich, dass
meine Lampen das mitmachen.
Okay, also ersteres kriegst du relativ easy
aus dem Server ausgelesen. Letzteres wird
sehr viel kompliziert.
Das ist ein bisschen komplizierter. Und dann
halt irgendwie die Home Assistant.
Aber das finde ich geil. Das finde ich großartig.
Es gibt ja, ich meine, Home Assistant ist ja
schon sehr, sehr frei. Es gibt ja schon zig
tausend Integrations, die Leute
gebaut haben. Wahrscheinlich gibt es. Ich muss wahrscheinlich hier unter den Integrations
nur mal nach Minecraft. Diesen extra
Hacks Store, Home Assistant Community
Store heißt das, glaube ich, HACS
und da sind ja nochmal
mehr Sachen drin, die einfach irgendjemand
auf GitHub so rumflacken hat und da
muss es doch fast, es gibt schon Minecraft Server
Integrations. Es gibt eine Minecraft Server Integration.
Da ist einfach die Minecraft Server.
Okay, du musst dir nur sagen,
okay.
Ja, geil.
Dann siehst du auch direkt
im GitHub, was der dir bietet.
Der bietet einen Binary Sensor und einen Sensor.
Was geben die aus?
Ah, nee, warte mal, das ist einfach.
Ich komme mal runter hier einfach, was dir der ausgibt.
So, I transpile
Connection Status. Und
Latenz, Number of Players, World Message.
Uh.
Aber den Game Mode,
aber nicht die Server Time.
Nee, nee. Ah.
Number of Online Players. Ich meine, das ist cool.
Kannst du das auch schon mal anzeigen lassen? Ja?
Okay, dann mache ich mir jetzt
eine Automation, die mir
anzeigt meine Freundin auf dem Minecraft.
Ja.
Man kann ja auch ganz, also ich habe zum Beispiel noch so eine Automation laufen, gerade an so einem State, die muss man nicht alles immer auf Lampen legen.
Das ist das Erste, wo man dran denkt.
Aber ich habe zum Beispiel am Laufen, wenn meine Wohnungstür aufgemacht wird und 30 Sekunden offen bleibt, dann kriege ich eine Notification.
Weil ich nicht möchte, dass ich aus Versehen die Tür offen lasse oder dass ich nicht merke, dass die Tür offen ist, weil Katzen.
Und die sollen nicht abhauen.
Und so kriege ich zumindest da den Hinweis.
Ich brauche nicht eine Notification, wenn die Tür offen ist.
Integration für die Chips in deinen Katzen.
Die haben auch keine Chips, aber das muss ich
lange mal machen. Da vergesse ich immer beim Tierarzt zu sagen,
dass ich das gerne machen würde.
Gibt es da nicht irgendwie sogar,
wenn deine Tiere gechippt sind,
dass du irgendeine Art...
Essentiell sind das RFID- oder NFC-Chips.
Genau, dass du einen Alarm kriegst,
wenn die nicht mehr in der Wohnung sind.
Das wäre auch stark. Es fühlt sich nach Überwachung an.
Aber für Haustiere ist das, glaube ich.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich glaube, den Haustieren ist es herzlich egal.
Genau.
Ja, das wäre stark.
Das würde meine Paranoia an manchen Stellen auch arg helfen.
Aber dann lass uns jetzt mal kurz zu den Protokollen
zurückkommen.
Eine Sache zum Protokoll, die ich vorhin noch ansprechen wollte.
Meine lustigsten
Devices, die ich mit drin hängen habe.
Ich habe mir vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
so LED-Kerzen gekauft.
Weil echte Kerzen sind halt auch scheiße, weil Katzen.
Und diese LED-Kerzen
stehen bei mir einfach im Fenster.
Und die kann ich eben
einschalten über so eine Fernbedienung.
Und das fand ich
ziemlich kacke, weil
ist ja Infrarot.
Und Infrarot ist ja
ein bisschen dumm
im Vergleich zu smarten Anwendigeräten
und kannst du halt nicht so einfach schicken.
Klar, du hast diese Fernbedienung, aber du musst halt
irgendwie dieses Infrarot sprechen können.
Und deswegen habe ich jetzt so einen IR-Blaster
bei mir zu Hause hängen im Wohnzimmer,
der einfach Infrarot spricht
und eine Home Assistant-Integration hat
und so kann ich diese Kerzen über Home Assistant
ein- und ausscheiden. Und ich kann die auch
über Infrarot halt zeitlich triggern.
Ich kann sagen, um drei Uhr nachts, spätestens bin ich safe im Bett und wenn die Kerzen ausfüllen, noch an waren, gehen die Kerzen wieder aus.
Und diese Kerzen gehen jetzt einfach automatisch jeden Tag eine Viertelstunde vor Sonnenuntergang an.
Und ich sitze einfach zu Hause, wo es gehen diese Kerzen an.
Aber diese Kerzen haben doch meistens eh irgendeinen Timer, oder?
Ja, die haben einen Timer-Modi, ja, aber dieser Timer-Modi ist ja nicht smart am Jahreszyklus festgemacht.
Das muss ja schon irgendwie mit dem Sonnenuntergang einstellen.
Und das kann Home Assistant für mich machen.
Bam!
Und was mein Fernseher hat, weil ich das zufällig, habe ich gleich ein zweites Problem erschlagen können.
Mein Fernseher hat manchmal das Problem,
weil auf meinem Fernseher Android läuft, was ich total dumm finde,
aber egal, dieser Fernseher war noch nie
im Internet, wahrscheinlich hat er irgendwelche Software-Updates,
aber der kriegt keine Software-Updates, weil er nicht ins Internet darf.
Bla, bla, bla.
Der Fernseher hat manchmal einen Bug,
dass er kein Audio ausgibt.
Alle paar Wochen passiert das mal.
Kannst du für Home Assistant über diesen
IR-Blaster deinen Fernseher ausmachen?
Ich kann ihn rebooten einfach.
Zum einen kann ich
mit dem IR-Blaster
ihn an- und ausschalten, das aber nicht den Reboot-Trigger
tatsächlich. Musst du dem IR-Blaster irgendwie
beibringen, dass er bestimmte Signale
imitiert? Ich kann über den IR-Blaster
kann ich meinem Fernseher
auch sagen, ich möchte bitte auf ein anderes
Gerät switchen. Dann kann ich einfach den Source,
den runterbutton und dann den OK button.
Also du bringst, musst diesem IR-Blaster
irgendwelche Fernbedienungsbefehle beibringen?
Genau, ich habe den quasi wie so eine Universal-Fernbedienung
kurz angelernt mit der
Fernsehfernbedienung. Und aber ich kann über
die smarte Steckdose, an der der Fernseher aus
Strommessgründen hängt, den ganzen Fernseher auch kurz
gebooten und Strom nehmen.
Und so, als ob ich aufsehen würde und das Kabel hänge. Und das hilft
gegen diesen Audiobug, den der wirklich alle fünf Wochen
oder so mal hat. Und ich
finde das so geil, dass ich solche dummen Sachen,
solche Sachen, die mich seit Jahren nerven,
in dieser Software abbilden
kann. Und es fühlt sich so overengineert,
dass ich auf der Couch sitze und dem Fernseher
kurz Strom nehme oder sagen, switch mal
bitte auf die Nintendo Switch, wenn er es nicht auto-selbstständig
mitbekommen hat, was eigentlich über
HDMI CIC recht problemlos
funktioniert, aber in einem von 20 Fällen eben
nicht. Jetzt kann ich das automatisieren.
und das fühlt sich so mächtig an.
Das ist das Schöne an der Home Assistant. Ich habe mich immer gefragt,
was macht man dafür in übertriebenen Zeugsprozessen,
um das Licht an- und auszumachen?
Aber es geht ja halt noch,
du kannst halt lauter Sachen in deiner
Umgebung damit skripten. Also allein
die Tatsache, dass ich,
dass du einstellen kannst,
macht das Radio an
oder macht die Stereoanlage an
oder genau sowas.
So einzelne Sachen sind halt nie so
sonderlich mächtig, aber in Kombination
spielst du das dann halt wirklich aus.
Wenn ich meine Balkontür aufmache,
wenn die zwei Minuten offen war,
geht meine Heizung in der Küche automatisch aus.
Und das ist uns so,
gut, das hatte ich mit HomeKit genau dasselbe schon vorher am Laufen.
Aber diese Möglichkeit, die mir das ermöglicht,
vorher habe ich die Heizung immer händisch ausgemacht,
bis auf den einen Tag, wo ich gemerkt habe,
aus Versehen, du hast sie nicht ausgemacht,
du hast sie außerdem voll aufgetreten.
Die war auch zwei Stunden jetzt auf der Fünf.
Toll, ganz, ganz großes Kino.
Aber das macht mir mein Leben einfach ein bisschen einfacher.
Das finde ich toll.
So, jetzt lassen wir uns mal zurück über Protokolle reden,
weil ich habe ja gerade aufgezählt,
Meine Sachen sind verbunden über
WiFi oder über
IP, über
Zigbee,
über DECT,
weil meine
Thermostate hier
an meiner Heizung sind die
Fritz-Thermostate, die über die
Fritzbox integriert sind. Und ich muss sagen,
so happy bin ich mit denen nicht, weil
die manchmal, wenn du ihnen einen Befehl gibst,
das garantiert
oder nur garantiert,
innerhalb der nächsten 10 Minuten umzusetzen.
und manchmal mache ich sie an
auf der UI
und dann kann ich zu dem Gerät hingehen und
OK drücken und wenn ich OK drücke, cykelt
der einmal ab, der jetzt mit der Fritzbox überdeckt,
weil es super stromsparend sein soll.
Und dann macht er das.
Es ist nicht dazu geeignet, zumindest in meinem Setup nicht,
dass ich mal schnell was an und aus mache.
Aber gut, bei der Heizung ist das eigentlich nicht so relevant.
Und Heizung ist an sich eh ein träges
System, aber ich könnte jetzt
keine Automation haben, wo ich sage,
aha, ein Tür- oder Fenstersensor
macht, dass die Heizung sofort ausgeht.
Aber das macht ja eh keinen Unterschied meistens,
weil der Thermostat ja auch träge, wie du schon
meinst, reagiert. Also theoretisch reicht
das, wenn er innerhalb von ein paar Minuten ausgeht.
Wahrscheinlich. Also ich habe
jetzt nochmal, ich habe IP, ich habe
Zigbee und ich habe Deckt. Und bei
dir, wie sind deine Geräte
jetzt angeschlossen? Ich glaube, das
meiste, wohl,
ja doch, die meisten Geräte, die meisten Smart Home Geräte
laufen tatsächlich über
HomeKit, beziehungsweise, also über altes
HomeKit, wo ich nicht weiß, was das für ein Protokoll ist.
beziehungsweise über Matter
und Thread, was die Neueren besseren können.
Ein paar Sachen direkt
über Matter, was ich ganz geil finde.
Noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Ansonsten ist das meiste halt
über Bluetooth oder WiFi auch
mit anzusprechen. Also über Bluetooth
läuft zum Beispiel dieses Aranet oder
dieser Knopf,
mein CO2-Messgerät, sorry, oder dieser
Knopf an der Tür, was aber
blöd ist, weil den würde ich gerne anders ansprechen,
weil wenn ich den über HomeKit trigger, über Bluetooth,
dann hat der eine massive Latenz.
bist der Trick.
Über Home Assistant, sorry,
wenn ich den über die Hersteller-App trigger,
die... Und du nimmst da
für dieses Gerät die
Integration, die du installierst
oder sagst du einfach
über Bluetooth füge neues Gerät hinzu und dann
pehrt sich dein Raspberry Pi automatisch mit diesem
Bluetooth-Gerät? Ich habe über die native
Bluetooth-Integration ausschließlich ein Device
konfiguriert und da weiß ich gerade
gar nicht, was das ist, weil mir das hier nicht angezeigt wird.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Gerät selber.
Ach so, dann habe ich über natives
Bluetooth gar nichts konfiguriert.
Die meisten Sachen sind über
irgendwie, es gibt diese Aranet-Integration
explizit selber für das CO2-S-Gerät,
die spricht aber Bluetooth, genauso wie die von dem Knopf,
die auch Bluetooth spricht.
Aber ansonsten sind die
meisten Sachen einfach über irgendwelche nativen.
Die AVM-Integration, die Apple-TV-Integration,
die Philips Hue-Integration,
die Matter-Integration ist ein bisschen generisch.
Die Apple-TV-Integration
redet mit einem Apple-TV-Gerät?
Die redet entweder mit Apple-TV
oder mit HomePods, weil es sind die Apple-TV-Siege.
wie Integration ist lol.
Aber die sind halt einfach Abspielgeräte und die können
mir einfach cool ihren Abspielzustand
eben geben.
Das sieht genauso aus wie das Bridget, was meine
Stay-On-Land ist. Ich finde das so geil, dass die Apple-TV-Integration
auch so
instant da war und die mir anzeigt,
was für Content läuft, egal in welcher
App das läuft, ob das die YouTube-App ist,
ob das die Plex-App ist, ob das
die Apple-TV-App ist. Das ist einfach so ein Broadcast-Netzwerk.
Ja, aber ich wusste gar nicht, dass Apple-TV das einfach
so nativ auch mit broadcastet
und ich hier einfach das Ding an- und ausschalten kann.
Ich kann Play und Pause machen.
Das läuft teilweise stabiler, als wenn ich das andersweitig machen würde.
Und das finde ich einfach beeindruckend.
Das ist sehr nice.
Aber hast du jetzt an deinen...
Du hast einen Raspberry Pi.
Das Home Assistant läuft auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Und hast du jetzt noch irgendwelche externe Peripherie an das Gerät reingesteckt?
Nein, da läuft ein nackter Raspberry Pi.
Also das ist nämlich das, was ich mich gefragt habe.
Das ist alles Software oder mitgebrachte Sachen, die der Raspberry kann.
Und das ist ein Raspberry Pi 4, 5, 2, 4, 4, 4, 4.
Also genauso wie ich. Und ich habe mich gefragt,
wenn ich jetzt Meta-Geräte kaufe, brauche ich
dafür für den Raspberry Pi
irgendeinen Hardware-Donkel oder Adapter?
Ich kann dir aber nicht sicher sagen,
ob der Pi direkt
Meta spricht oder ob der Pi mit einer
existierenden Meta-Bridge spricht,
was ich ja zum Beispiel in Form von meinem Apple TV oder
HomePod habe. Da bin
ich mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher.
Das wird es nämlich wahrscheinlich sein, weil
nachdem wir uns das erste Mal
darüber unterhalten hatten, hatte ich mich kurz in
Meta und Thread und ich schmeiße sie durcheinander.
Das ist jetzt nicht der Podcast, wo ihr alles darüber lernt,
aber ich hatte mich da mal kurz
reingelesen und eins von
beiden, ich glaube,
das eine baut auf dem anderen auf.
Oder auch nicht? Also ich glaube, man
spricht Thread over Matter. Das ist so, was ich
im Kopf rumschmucken habe.
Und es ist ein Mesh-Netzwerk
und das Mesh-Netzwerk hat unterschiedliche
Entry-Points und Ingresses
und Verteilserver.
Und wenn du, du nimmst einfach
an diesem Netzwerk teil und du kannst bestimmte
Rollen einnehmen. Genau. Und wenn
du natürlich... Also Thread Repeater sein oder
du kannst... Das heißt, dein Raspberry Pi
muss gar nichts können, aber es geht bei dir
wahrscheinlich out of the box, weil du
Homepods hast. Ich vermute. Das ist
pures Vermutungswissen, aber das würde
zumindest gut passen zu dem, wie ich das Setup
verstehe, ja. Okay, das heißt,
das bringt mir persönlich gar nichts,
weil ich keinerlei Homepods besitze.
Aber wenn du auch nur ein so ein Gerät hast,
würde das quasi eine ganze Menge
Use-Case sein. Nicht, dass ich jetzt unbedingt dafür werben möchte,
dass man sich ein Homepod kaufen möchte, aber
das wäre zum Beispiel
ein Entrypoint. Das würde erklären, warum es bei dir
ohne weiteres ging und bei mir
potenziell nicht.
Aber das ist cool zu wissen.
Ich habe dann nämlich geguckt und
angefangen, mir halt diverse Geräte
immer die Zigbee-Variante rauszusuchen,
weil ich das ja habe.
Was ich zum Beispiel
habe, was ich noch hatte, bevor ich
auf eine bestimmte Sorte Glühbirnen umgestiegen bin,
ist, ich habe bestimmt so eine Stange
Zigbee-Steckdosen,
die zum Beispiel an dem
hängen und damit kann ich den Ventilator
an- und ausmachen.
Und der Ventilator hat ja eine 1, 2, 3, 0
Stufeneinstellung.
Aber was,
wenn du dir die Update
Videos oder die Release Notes
von Home Assistant anguckst, was da manchmal
dazukommt, sind extra Widgets für
Ventilatoren oder für Lüfter.
Die kannst du halt nicht nutzen, wenn du diese...
Und ich frage, ja, das geht
natürlich mit meiner An-Aus-Steck-Dose nicht.
geben, dass es ein Ventilator dahinter ist.
Okay, das schon. Aber die Integration
ist natürlich nur Strom an oder aus.
Aber
spannend wäre, was muss ich
mir denn für einen Ventilator kaufen?
Es gibt ziemlich viele über Infrarot gesteuerte
Hardware in der Richtung.
Also die mit über einer Fernbedienung einfach Infrarot
gesteuert werden. Und die sind dann automatisch
dekriert, weil ich mir so ein IR-Blaster
mit so einem IR-Blaster ansprechen.
Und das kannst du dann
hoffentlich als... Diese Integration, dass man
mit einem IR-Blaster alles, was so eine
Infrarot-Verbedingungen hat, erschlagen kann,
ist natürlich eine geile Idee,
da habe ich noch nicht drüber nachgedacht.
Weil ich glaube, die meisten Geräte,
die ich dann unter dem Stichwort
Zigbee-Ventilator oder
Home-Automation-Ventilator gesucht habe,
sind dann eigentlich Deckventilatoren.
Ja, genau, da gibt es relativ viel, das stimmt.
Und ich meine, weitere Use-Cases
nach Heizkörpern
wären natürlich so Sachen wie, wenn man es hat,
Klimaanlagen
oder manchmal
kleinere Ventilatoren,
und ähnliche Sachen.
Ja, ich habe bei mir bloß noch meine
Homekit-Heizung, Thermostate
mit drin, aber
ich muss sagen, an sich
finde ich das Rückblicken gar nicht
mehr so relevant.
Nee, weil du die nicht häufig genug benutzt.
Eben, und Heizungen haben Thermostate
eingebaut. Ich könnte meine Heizkörper im
Wohnzimmer einfach den gesamten
theoretisch immer auf drei
stehen lassen. Im Sommer vielleicht mal ausmachen,
weil es manchmal kühl wird, aber
theoretisch heizen die ja auch nur,
wenn sie es brauchen. Genau.
Also eigentlich ein Thermostat, die
Dinger, die du vorher dran hattest, wo du von
Snowflake bis 5
einstellen konntest. Ja, also die
sind schon mächtig genug für das, was ich
eigentlich brauche. Das Einzige, wo ich es halt wirklich nutze,
wo ich das smarte Feature nutze,
ist in der Küche, weil da eben eine Balkontür
daneben ist. Und dass ich das Ding eben
komplett ausschalten kann, wenn die Balkontür offen ist.
Das ist wirklich ein Feature, was ich
nutze. Also bei den
Thermostaten habe ich
irgendwann festgestellt, dass ich
die Einstellung in der Fritzbox
vornehmlich benutze.
Also auch nur
die UI, die
Smart Home Einstellung innerhalb der
Fritzbox ist furchtbar.
Aber man
muss halt nur ein, zwei, dreimal im Jahr
von einem Template aufs
andere Template umsteigen und dann gehen die
Heizkörper zu bestimmten Uhrzeiten an oder
aus. Ja, also was viele Leute machen ist,
dass sie sich halt so in der Zeit, wo sie nicht
zu Hause sind, die Heizung natürlich ausschalten können.
Und das ist auch völlig valide. Sehe ich absolut ein, dass man vielleicht nachts anders heizt als tagsüber.
Auf der anderen Seite will ich persönlich nie, dass es bei mir arschkalt ist, weil die Katzen auch nicht frieren sollen.
Achso, die Katzen sollen nicht frieren, die haben Fellklären.
Ja, und wahrscheinlich ist es denen auch egal, aber ich will einfach, dass es in meiner Wohnung quasi kontinuierlich ca. 19, 20 Grad sind.
Das ist die Temperatur, bei der ich mich wohlfühle und das ist die Temperatur, die einfach immer sein kann.
Also wirklich immer, immer.
Und im Sommer läuft die Heizung ja automatisch nicht,
wenn es eh wärmer als das ist.
Also ich habe bei mir das zumindest so eingestellt,
dass die Temperatur, wenn ich tagsüber auf Arbeit bin,
auch gerne auf unter.
Aber ich habe auch keine Katzen, die erfrieren zu Hause.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wäre das denen auch scheißegal.
Wahrscheinlich ist das denen auch wirklich egal,
wenn es tagsüber dann 17, 16 Grad in der Wohnung wären.
Aber weiß nicht.
Dann knudeln die sich so niedlich aneinander.
Nein, das machen die beiden.
Ah, mein Minecraft-Server verbindet sich nicht mit meinem Home Assistant.
Hendrik versucht, das hier gerade live zu konfigurieren.
Aber ja, vielleicht haben wir langsam mal auch genug über Home Assistant gequatscht, habe ich das Gefühl.
Was sind denn so Sachen, also ich habe jetzt auch schon aufgezählt, die Minecraft-Integration, wir haben gerade gemerkt, ich kann die Uhrzeit vom Server leider noch nicht damit auslesen, aber vielleicht findet sich noch irgendwas.
Was ist denn noch eine Automatisierung, die du mit deinem Home Assistant ausprobieren möchtest? Was ist denn noch ein Feature, was du damit unbedingt mal probieren willst?
Ich dachte, ich hätte
eine Liste von
HomeKit-Integrations, die ich
gerne machen, ausprobieren will, aber
anscheinend habe ich die mal... Home Assistant.
Home Assistant-Sachen. Anscheinend habe ich die schon mal
gelöscht oder abgearbeitet.
Das eine, was mich bloß noch stört,
was hier steht, ist, dass
ich gerne mir die HomeKit-Integration
nochmal anschauen wollte, sprich die Home Assistant
Devices in HomeKit reinhängen.
Aber das war alles so frickelig, da habe ich einfach gar
keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Manche Sachen lässt man auch einfach sein.
Das Fricklichste, okay, das könnte man auch noch aufsehen.
Was ist das Fricklichste, was du gemacht hast?
Ja, das waren die HomeKit-Devices.
Das war genau die HomeKit-Devices,
aus HomeKit rauskriegen,
in HomeKit unpairn
und dann aber mit HomeKit in den Pairing-Modus bringen
und dann mit dem Home Assistant verbinden.
Weil das hat fünfmal pro Device fehlgeschlagen
und beim nächsten Mal ging es dann.
Und das hat mich mega angekotzt,
dass ich da bestimmt drei Stunden lang gesessen habe,
dass für meine Heizungsthermostate,
für die paar Steckdosen und für die
Tür-Sensoren, von denen ich drei Stück habe.
Also an Fenster, Wohnungstür
und an der
Balkontür, dass ich die alle da reingekriegt
habe. Mittlerweile lief es dann halt alles und
seitdem ist es auch ganz okay, also wie gesagt,
bis auf der Stabilitäts-Issue, dass die einmal am Tag
circa unavailable werden und ein Reboot
da hilft. Aber die reinzukriegen,
initial,
boah, war das kacke.
Und bei dir? Diese Lampe da oben
ist die Deckenlampe in meinem Flur
und da sind drei Birnen drin.
und das sind drei
gut zehn Lampen.
Das sind also die mit den zwei Nupsis.
Die man so reindreht und dann so ein paar
Grad halbschraubt, genau.
Und
die musst du paren.
Und die habe ich alle angemacht,
alle reingeschraubt und
weißt du, wie man eine Zigbee-Lampe pärt?
War das so ein Ding von wegen, du musst
den Schalter zehnmal drücken und dann ist die im Paring-Mode?
Du machst sie
fünfmal an und aus.
Aber warte mal, du hast drei Lampen.
So.
Die über den selben Scheiter laufen.
Du gehst in dem Home Assistant,
in die Decon's Integration, in die Foscon Web App,
in die Unterseite Einstellungen,
Geräte hinzufügen.
So weit zu gucken, macht man ja nicht ständig.
Aber dann habe ich
drei Lampen gleichzeitig dort oben hinzugefügt.
Oder sagen wir es so, ich habe zu dem Zeitpunkt
eh an dem Abend zehn Lampen hinzugefügt.
Aber das sind drei Lampen,
die an demselben An- und Ausstecker
hart hängen.
Und das heißt, ich habe natürlich einfach gedacht,
das wird schon funktionieren.
Ich mache an, aus, an, aus, an, aus.
Und dann machen sie alle.
Flipp, flipp, flipp.
Und in meinem Home, in meiner Zigbee UI,
taucht exakt eine davon aus.
Ah, scheiße.
Also stehe ich da.
Glücklicherweise geht es ja auf dem Telefon,
auf dem Tablet und auf dem Laptop alles gleich gut.
Du weißt ja auch nicht, welche das ist.
Naja, doch.
Weil du hast sie dann verbunden
und dann kannst du sie auch steuern.
Aber verliert die Apparing, wenn du sie wieder rausnimmst?
Nee, weil du kannst ja nicht unterscheiden,
ob sie drin steckt oder ob der Strom abgedreht ist.
Ach so, also kannst du theoretisch die eine wieder rausnehmen,
die gepairt ist.
So, ich hab dann gedacht, ich probier das jetzt einfach noch mal,
aber wenn du die alle drei noch fünfmal an- und ausmachst,
dann ist die erste, die du schon gepairt hast,
wieder zurückgesetzt.
Das heißt, ich stand auf der Leiter und habe zwei rausgedreht
und eine drin gehabt, fünfmal den Knopf gedrückt,
diese haben wir verbunden.
Und dann die
wieder rausgedreht,
wieder eine andere reingedreht.
Und das habe ich dann insgesamt dreimal gemacht.
Geil. Was auch schön ist, ist manchmal,
wenn ich neue
Fernbedienungen hinzufüge, diese
Hue-Fernbedienungen sind ja auch über Zigbee
verbunden. Ich weiß nicht, wie deine Fernbedienungen
verbunden sind, wahrscheinlich dann auch über Meta irgendwie,
falls du irgendwelche hast.
Und die haben
manchmal, die aus
irgendeinem Grund, ich weiß es nicht,
wie es passiert, wenn ich so eine Fernbedienung
da gibt es auch auf der Fernbedienung
kann man hinten aufmachen
oder mit einer Nadel irgendeinen Knopf reindrücken
und dann zählt man bis Ende.
Und die hat manchmal
gerade die von Hue haben manchmal
aus irgendeinem Grund
dann Bock in so einen Peer-to-Peer-Modus zu gehen
und sich mit der erstbesten Glühbirne
in der Nähe zu paaren.
Das geht auch bei diesen Trattfri-Lampen.
Du brauchst keinen Hub oder irgendwas.
Du hast einfach eine Fernbedienung
und eine Glühbirne und du kannst die direkt miteinander bauen.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
hat bloß bei mir dazu geführt, dass jedes Mal, wenn ich eine bestimmte
Fernbedienung resettet habe,
dass ich hinterher auch eine Lampe resetten muss.
Das Erste, was passiert ist, ist die Fernbedienung
also ich resette die Fernbedienung
und irgendeine Glühbirne in meinem Wohnzimmer
fängt anzuklinken.
Was ein Aufwand.
Und dann merke ich, ah, ich kann plötzlich diese Glühbirne
steuern. Also anfangs
darf ich ja, wir erzählen euch, wie cool
Home Assistant ist, aber es gibt schon
echt ein paar sehr interessante Schmerzen,
die man haben kann.
With great power comes great annoyance.
Aber ja, also wenn ihr an dieses Thema
einsteigen wollt, es gibt sehr viel, was man machen kann.
Man kann sich einen,
wenn ihr bereits Hue habt,
dann bleibt besser bei Hue.
Wenn ihr
euch ein Dresden Elektronik
oder ähnliches Zigbee
Gerät kaufen wollt,
das ist auf der Home Assistant Seite auch ganz gut
erklärt, dann kann man so gut
wie jede Hue oder fast jede
Hue Trattfree
oder inner-Sigby-Lampe nehmen. Man kann auch
explizit nach den Glühbirnen suchen und
von Hue und Ikea,
also Trattfri ist Ikea,
kann man auch diverse
Fernbedienungen dann benutzen. Ich habe mir
diese 5 Euro
Dimmer-Fernbedienungen von
Ikea geholt und die sind
super cool, weil man die magnetisch,
die kann man irgendwo rankleben und dann haben die so einen kleinen
Magneten, das heißt ich habe die auf meine
echten
Lichtschalter geklebt.
Nicht Fernbedienungen, doch Lichtschalter. Das heißt, wenn du den drückst,
drückst du den hinteren Schalter gleich mit.
Nee, ja.
Ich habe kurz überlegt, ob ich mir so
Lichtschalter hole, die ich austauschen kann.
Ja, sowas habe ich mir mal gekauft, aber ich habe das
noch nie installiert,
nachdem ich gemerkt habe, ja, du musst den Schalter,
okay, du musst den abnehmen, das war mir vorher schon klar,
aber du musst ja auch die Kabel, die ja unter
recht viel Strom stehen, also natürlich, wenn wir die Sicherung
raus, auf jeden Fall, aber
eine gewisse Verantwortung.
Also es ist, glaube ich, wenn ihr schon Hue habt,
dann einfach noch Home Assistant oben drüber bügeln,
ist auf jeden Fall noch eine zusätzliche
Ja, und so blöd das klingt, ein homogenes
System macht einem da
wirklich echt weniger Probleme als ein sehr
heterogenes Setup, wo alles wirklich hier durch die Kante
fliegt. Also es ist ja auch...
Aber? Es ist jetzt noch nicht
reines Convenience Features, es ist auch ein bisschen Hobby.
Ja, aber Home Assistant ermöglicht dir halt
auch den heterogensten Schwachsten
alles miteinander zu koppeln. Ja, genau, es
schnürt einfach alles zusammen. Und das klappt
richtig gut. Und das ist
echt toll.
Genau. Ich hab
mein Home Assistant hat ja auch
eine Integration, eine
eine
ist das die DLNA
Integration? Ne, die macht bloß, dass er
die Musik auf meinem NAS sieht, aber es gibt noch
eine zweite NAS Integration, die sich
immer mal wieder resettet. Also meine, hast du
Ich hab die Synology Integration noch mit drin.
Genau. Und mich, ich
hab irgendwann Fehlermeldung von meinem Home Assistant bekommen, weil ich
ihm eingestellt hab, dass er regelmäßig Backups machen soll
von der Konfiguration. Und die hat er einfach
bei sich auf dem Raspberry Pi gespeichert und irgendwann war der
jedes davon ist voll.
Ich habe doch Peripherie angeschossen. Bei mir klemmt ein USB-Stick
dran. Das nutzt er als Data Drive und die Backups da drauf zu speichern.
Ja, das ist praktisch. Und diese
Backups sind nämlich ein paar
Megabyte groß. 80 MB oder 100 MB
Sieger. Manchmal ja und das macht er jeden Tag eins.
Und ich habe ihm dann einfach irgendwann
so konfiguriert, dass er die Backups
einfach auf meinem NAS speichert.
Nice. Das ist cool. Das musst du
mir sagen, wie das geht, weil das ist noch die
eine Angst, die ich habe, dass der Pi und der
Stick irgendwie abrauchen, weil ich will das nie wieder
neu konfigurieren. Und von allem, was ich online lese,
ist Home Assistant auch unglaublich
toll, wenn du ein Backup hast und du hast
ein neues Device, dann sagst du einfach Backup und
alle deine Geräte sind da und es geht einfach.
Das ist insofern nice, dass ich
einen Großteil der Konfiguration auf diesem Decon-Stick
habe. Das heißt, ich könnte den Decon-Stick auch an
einen frischen Raspberry Pi ranstecken und dann würden
die Geräte bereits gepaart sein.
Und ich habe auch schon Tage damit
verbracht, das alles von vorne einzurichten.
Dann sind halt ein paar Stunden weg und wenn man
dabei Musik hört, ist es ganz nett. Aber man
möchte es natürlich nicht ständig.
Nee, nee. Es ist schön, wenn es läuft.
Man kann viel damit machen, aber
alles auf einen Stapel
einzurichten, ist schon ein Drecksaufnahme.
Genau. Und ja, es gibt halt extra
Home Assistant User auf meiner
Fritzbox für die REST API von der
Fritzbox und eine extra
Home Assistant User auf
meinem
NAS für solche Sachen.
Da habe ich nicht dran gedacht. Das ist sehr klug.
Vielleicht muss ich das nochmal arbeiten.
Du hast ja irgendwie offenbar auch eine Webcam
an deinem Home Assistant angeschlossen.
Also Home Assistant kann nicht gut mit Kameras.
Ich habe eine Kamera zu Hause und die hängt nur in HomeKit.
Achso, es gibt dieses eine, diese eine Kachel, die ich hier verwende.
Ich wollte mal nachgucken, wie die heißt.
Da kannst du für einen bestimmten Raum nehmen und das ist eine, wie heißt denn die?
Das ist ein Area Card.
Und da kannst du sagen, du bist jetzt hier die Area für mein Schlafzimmer.
Da habe ich jetzt ein Foto von meinem Schlafzimmer.
Da siehst du Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit und kannst das Licht an- und ausmachen.
und kann das hier, wenn du draufklickst,
dann in irgendein Subview rein navigieren
und das gibt dir als Einstellung
die Möglichkeit, entweder ein Foto zu nehmen
oder als Hintergrundbild,
wo ist es eingerichtet,
ein
Webcam-Theme,
Webcam-Stream als Hintergrundbild.
Das heißt, du könntest da irgendwie
eine Webcam haben. Okay, da muss ich mich nochmal anschauen,
weil mein letzter Stand war Home Assistant,
Kameras, Integration sind alle ein bisschen
fricklig komisch.
Ich würde das auch nicht machen, ich finde das prinzipiell cool,
diese Ansicht zu haben, dass du siehst
hier, aber ich möchte auch nicht meine ganze Wohnung
mit Kamera ausgestanden. Nee, das will ich auch nicht.
Ich habe nur diese eine Kamera, die auf meine
Wohnungstür von innen schaut.
Vielleicht bin ich an der Stelle
ein bisschen paranoid, aber ich habe immer die Angst,
also, das ist wirklich
eine weirde Angst, aber ich habe die Angst,
dass bei mir eingebrochen wird. Das ist gar
nicht mal so schlimm, aber die Tatsache,
dass dann die Katzen abhauen
oder, das würde, also
da habe ich Angst vor und deswegen
muss ich mir manchmal einfach verifizieren,
dass die scheiß Tür vor denen zu ist.
Hast du dich mal mit den,
also, wenn du deine Katzen
irgendwann gechippt haben wirst,
würde mich mal interessieren, was du dann,
du wirst dann natürlich
in irgendein Rabbit Hole reinkriechen
und dich mit diesen Chips auseinandersetzen.
Mich würde mal interessieren, was es dann so an Hardware gibt,
um irgendwie im Umkreis von
ein paar hundert Metern seine Katzen zu
ordnen. Ob sowas wie Find My für
Haustiere gibt. Also nicht, dass ich wüsste,
weil gerade wenn das NFC spricht,
was willst du denn da machen? Achso, das ist bloß, man muss
direkt rangehen und dann... Die Lesegeräte sind
alle Hals an die Katze ran.
Das ist nichts, also das ist
kein Feindmeinend.
Vielleicht gibt es ja eine
Variante mit einer größeren
Funkreichweite oder so. Ich weiß ja nicht.
Aber ich weiß, dass ein Kollege
von mir hat an den Halsbinder seiner Katzen
AirTags dran, aber er nutzt das nicht
zum Finden, sondern er hat die Katzen
darauf trainiert, dass wenn
die im Garten irgendwo rumrennen und er
die AirTags anpingt und
dass sie dann Essen kriegen. Sprich, er muss die einmal
anpingen und die Katzen kommen reingerannt.
Uh, das ist gut.
Das ist ein anderer Hack.
Der könnte wahrscheinlich auch einfach eine Pfeife nehmen, aber somit
hat er im Worst Case auch die Möglichkeit,
die Katze zu finden.
Ich glaube, da ist schon sehr viel
Seelenfrieden mit verbunden, wenn du weißt, dass du das ist.
Potenziell, ja.
Was ist das Fricklichste, was du mit deinem Home Assistant hast?
Ah, das war der Home Assistant-Kram.
Ah ja, stimmt.
Aber ich glaube, wir haben auch mittlerweile
erst mal genug zu
Home Assistant.
Das ist ein großes Thema.
Vielleicht
holen wir es mal irgendjemand. Wenn ihr Bock habt
oder wenn ihr viel an Home Assistant rumbastelt,
sagt mal Bescheid, dann können wir uns
noch eine dritte Person mit dazu holen und nochmal über
Home Assistant abnürfen. Ich kenne noch mindestens zwei andere Leute,
die Home Assistant doch schon länger verwenden als ich.
Und da mit MQTT
in Home Assistant rumgespielt haben.
Nice. Das machen wir auch noch.
Holen wir uns auch mit rein.
Aber ich glaube, wir haben jetzt
zwei Stunden wahrscheinlich schon zu dem Thema.
wir müssen langsam mal was anderes.
Anderthalb.
Wir können auch gerne noch über Minecraft reden.
Stimmt, das hatten wir auch.
Oh, andersrum,
nicht Minecraft in Home Assistant hängen,
sondern dass du deine Home Assistant-Sachen
in Minecraft sehen kannst. Dass du irgendwo
so ein Schild hast, wo deine
Buttons in Minecraft, die dein Licht in der
echten Welt triggern. Das will ich.
Ich meine, wenn das geht, auf jeden Fall.
Aber
das ist ja quasi
der eine Use Case einfach nur
die Tageszeit in Minecraft
in meinem Licht, in meinem Zimmer.
Nein, nein, ich will es andersrum.
Ich will von Minecraft aus Home Assistant
Events schicken können.
Sodass ich einen Button in Minecraft drücke
und daran was physisches kette.
Oder dass ich, keine Ahnung,
mein
Licht ist so,
aber ich kann so eine Redstone-Fackel,
die angeht, wenn ich
in Home Assistant,
ich kann nicht über Home Assistant tückern, die Redstone-Fackel
oder so.
Sowas.
Was macht man mit Redstone-Fackeln?
Keine Ahnung, Redstone-Fackeln sind halt eine LED quasi.
Also du kannst darüber... Ach, die kann man an- und ausmachen?
Du kannst die an- und ausmachen. Ach, witzig.
Hast du schon mal Kerzen gemacht in Minecraft?
Das ist was anderes als eine Fackel?
Eine Kerze ist eine Kerze, die macht man
aus Bienenwachs. Es gibt
Bienenwachs? Es gibt Bienen.
Die hab ich schon mal gesehen.
man kann Bienen
domestizieren.
Du kannst die domestizieren?
Ja, dann fliegen die, du kannst
entweder die aus ihren eigenen,
also es ist in bestimmten
Biomen spawnen
Bienenstöcke
mit einer 1 zu 20
Wahrscheinlichkeit an Bäumen,
wenn die Bäume direkt neben einer Blume stehen.
Oh, okay. Also du kannst das auch
wir hatten mal
aus Versehen einen Bienenstock kaputt gemacht
und dann hab ich 20 Minuten
da gesessen und Bäume
mit Bone Meal
gespawnt neben Blumen,
um irgendwie diese Bienenstöcke wiederherzustellen.
Und man kann die, wenn man
ein Lagerfeuer unten drunter macht,
dann sind die pacified
und stechen dich nicht und dann kann man
man sieht den Füllzustand,
diese Bienen fliegen halt
zwischen Blumen und dem Stock hin und her
und mit einer Schere kann man dann
das Wachs rausholen und mit dem Wachs kann man
oder
Honeycomb kriegt man raus, nicht direkt Wachs, aber aus dem
kommt, direkt kann man auch Kerzen herstellen.
Und was sind Kerzen? Was machen die anders als eine
Fackel? Kerzen sind
fast dasselbe wie eine Fackel, außer dass sie nicht an der Wand kleben
können. Sie sehen schöner
aus. Sie sind an einer Stelle.
Stehen sie so wie eine Fackel, kann man ja auch
einfach so irgendwo draufstellen. Aber man kann
noch bis zu vier Kerzen an eine Stelle
stellen. Da stehen da vier Kerzen. Und man macht die an und aus
und sieht hübsch aus.
Cool. Ja. Das ist
cool. Man kann Kerzen färben.
Du kannst rote
und gelbe Kerzen haben. Wie so Lapislazo
auf Kerzen werfen, das ist eine blaue Kerze.
Ich habe letztens ein
YouTube-Video über die
spannende Geschichte der blauen LED gesehen
und wie unglaublich komplex
es war, blaue LEDs zu schaffen.
Und dass ja heutige
Displays gar nicht möglich wären, wenn wir
diese Technologie einfach nicht gehabt hätten.
Das war ein Veritasium-Video.
Veritasium, ja.
Du,
wir gehen jetzt zu den Picks.
Das ist dein
Favorite-Minecraft-Nein-Quatsch.
Nee, lass uns über die Pics reden, auf jeden Fall
Ja, ich fange mal an
weil ich habe einen Spaß-Pic mitgebracht
und das ist ein
O1-Algorithm to check if a number
is a prime
that works in 95% of all cases
In 95%
of all cases?
Das ist einfach wie Turnforce
Das ist gut
Die haben Implementierung
in zigtausend gefühlt Sprachen
unter anderem auch
Englisch, wo einfach No steht.
Oder auch natürlich
Finnisch, German ist natürlich auch, da war
Nein-Datei und diverse
Programmiersprachen, auch
natürlich so tolle Sachen wie Holy
C oder Intercal.
Also
literally alles implementiert, aber es ist halt
überall nur Return.
Das erinnert mich daran, dass es mal ein
NPM-Package namens 13 gab.
Five gab es, Returns gives you five.
Genau, es return einfach.
Aber es hatte auch haufenweise Convenience Methods.
Du konntest auch zum Beispiel 5.German sagen,
dann kam halt der String 5 raus.
Das Beste war 5.Smooth,
dann kam ein S raus.
Das ist Prime.
Ein tolles Repo.
Ich mag Spaß-Repos.
Wo wir bei Spaß-Sachen sind.
Und wo ich jetzt weiß,
dass dein Lieblings-Editor jetzt VS Code ist,
in City, die Extension VS Code Pets.
Ist es das, was ich denke, was es ist?
quasi ein Tamagotchi in VS Code.
Das ist
nicht ganz so
advanced, aber du hast dann
hier ein kleines Panel
und da läuft ein kleines Tier drin rum.
Ich muss mal, glaube ich, hier die Zoom
das Stufen, so ein kleines Pixeltierchen.
Ich habe hier hinzugefügt eine Katze und einen Hund und die
reden mit dir.
Und du hast hier einen Knopf, also du kannst
die auch wieder löschen.
Du kannst die nicht löschen.
Dieser Button könnte auch entfernt werden.
Don't you dare press it.
Aber man kann halt noch beliebig viele andere.
Es gibt Katzenhunde, Schildkröten, Fögel,
das ist alles mögliche.
Und dieser Knopf hier wirft den Ball
und dann jagen die den Ball.
Das ist wunderbar.
Jetzt hat die Katze den Ball gefangen.
Das ist so großartig.
Kleine Pixeltierchen für dein Wierskot.
Das ist ein Niedes.
Ich hoffe, deine echten Katzen werden nicht eifersüchtig.
Die lieben aber auch manche Bälle.
Nicht alle Bälle, manche Bälle.
Ja, ich...
Achso.
Ein Pick, den ich noch habe, wenn wir schon bei Spielen sind,
ist, ich habe mal eine Awesome-Liste verlinkt.
Und zwar, was ich sehr gerne
spiele, sind Spiele, die
irgendwie, wo man
was bauen kann, beziehungsweise was ich auch sehr gerne
mag, sind Spiele, wo du Code schreiben kannst.
Sowas wie Transported, wo du in Lua
so kleine Züge programmierst,
dass die halt sich richtig verhalten. Oder
Elevator Saga, wo du in JavaScript
einen Aufzug programmierst. Das sind Spiele, die ich noch nicht kenne,
die ich unbedingt ausprobieren muss. Das sind unglaublich tolle Sachen.
Und was ich hier verlinkt habe, ist Awesome Engineering
Games. Ist noch eine sehr, sehr
viel längere Liste, als man erwarten würde.
Und die haben zu den verschiedensten Themen, ob das jetzt
Transportation und Route Management, was ich gerade meinte, oder City Building,
Vehicle Building, Bridge Building,
Job Simulators,
Hacking und Computer Science.
Also zu den verschiedensten Themenbereichen
haufenweise Spiele aufgelistet, weil das einfach
tolle Spiele sind. Und das sind Spiele,
in denen man jeweils jedes Mal Code schreiben muss?
Nee, nee, nee. Auch die unterschiedlichen Sachen. Factorius zum Beispiel auch.
Factory Building ist mit dabei.
das bessere Factorio,
Mindestry.
Alles mögliche. Es gibt auch Open World Survival
Sandboxes einfach. Da ist jetzt Valheim
oder Hydro Neo oder ich glaube Minecraft
ist hier sicherlich auch in der Liste.
Nein, es ist nicht,
aber es ist erwähnt unter Factorio.
Aber die Liste
ist sehr, sehr lang und da sind tolle Sachen
dran und ich liebe gerade solche
Programmierspiele, weil die unglaublich cool sind.
Ich habe lange mal, das war so ein Java
geschriebenes Battlebots-Dings,
wo du so einen kleinen,
ein kleiner Roboter,
der in so einer Arena rumgefahren ist und der konnte schießen.
Und du hast immer so zwei Roboter, die
einander gebettelt haben. Und ich glaube, drei Treffer
haben den anderen eben explodieren lassen.
Und du konntest halt komplett
die Logik des Roboters schreiben.
Und da hat man halt angefangen und hat, das war
im ersten, zweiten, dritten Semester oder so.
Das ging so ein bisschen nach so einem Interviewspiel.
Es war unglaublich cool. Es hat mir mega Spaß gemacht.
Und irgendwann habe ich mir mal andere
Logik von
Leuten aus dem Forum runtergeladen.
Und die Leute, die das halt so richtig am oberen Limit der Highscores immer waren, also dein Code konntest du hochladen und du konntest dann an so Matches teilnehmen.
Aber die Leute, die immer die meisten Punkte hatten, die haben alle dieselbe Taktik genutzt.
Und das fand ich damals so abgefahren. Das hatte aber so einen coolen Namen, das war irgendwie so Probability Wave Riding oder so.
Und sie sind auf den Wahrscheinlichkeitswellen
hin und her geritten quasi und hin und her
gefahren, wo deine Kugeln
wahrscheinlich hinfliegen, wenn du schießen
würdest. Und du konntest die einfach nicht mehr treffen.
Das war unmöglich.
Die sind ausgewichen auf den
Wahrscheinlichkeitswellen. Und das fand ich so
abgefahren krank.
Das ist schon unglaublich cool. Man muss ja auch nicht gegen die
Ultra dann direkt
spielen. Also da gab es auch sehr simple
AIs, gegen die du angetreten bist oder gegen die
du entwickeln konntest. Fand ich mega cool.
Das macht mir mega Spaß.
Das erinnert mich an ein anderes Veritasium-Video,
wo es um Game Theory ging
und da war glaube ich auch das Ergebnis,
dass
ein Wettbewerb
ausgeschrieben wurde,
um das Prisoner-Dilemma
zu gewinnen
und es gab am Anfang
drei naive, die man
oder drei oder fünf naive
Algorithmen, sowas wie
sei kooperativ, sei
malicious oder
mach immer das gleiche oder sowas.
Und innerhalb dieser fünf
Basic-Algorithmen, die da vorgegeben wurden,
war direkt der ideale Algorithmus
drin. Danach wurden noch viel komplexere und
krassere Algorithmen gefunden, aber für
so Prisoner Dilemma auf
Dauer war dann
einer von diesen naiven sofort
immer der ideale Algorithmus.
Witzigerweise, da hat nie wieder jemand einen besseren gefunden.
Spannend.
Hast du noch einen Pick?
Weil du ein Awesome
aufgezählt hast, etwas,
womit ich mich neulich wieder wenig auseinandersetzen wollte,
weil ich
ein Dokument erzeugen wollte.
Natürlich late ich.
Aber late ich absolut nicht mehr verwenden wollte,
ist
Tippst.
Über Tippst hatten wir schon ein, zwei Mal geredet,
vor ein paar Monaten.
Das Schöne ist, mittlerweile gibt es
viele, viele, viele Templates
für Sachen in Tippst.
Ich habe hier natürlich eine Seite, die natürlich heißt
Awesome Tippst.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es, wenn ich es jetzt so suche,
noch zwei, drei andere aus dem Tipps.
Aus dem Tipps.
Tipps, Tipps.
Und die
Integration von Tipps
in VS Code
ist auch relativ nice. Also ich hatte, das startet
automatisch im Hintergrund so ein
Watch und
du kannst deine Vorschau-PDF
direkt hier an der Seite aufmachen. Das ist super nice.
Und ja, ich
hab's in die Show Notes gepackt, wenn ihr Dokumente
erstellen wollt. Keine Ahnung.
eure Diplomarbeit,
wissenschaftliche Papers,
euer nächstes Buch,
ein CV für eine Bewerbung
oder eine Rechnung.
Tut euch nicht den Schmerz von Latech an.
Ja, Latech muss nicht mehr sein.
Nein.
Tipps ist das bessere Latech.
Also ich bin ja auch, es gibt
schon allein wesentlich sinnvollere
Fehlermeldungen.
Fehlernzeile 0. Have fun finding it,
fucker. Genau, aber eine Sache,
mir aufgefallen ist, die auch Tipps noch nicht
gut gemacht hat in dem Moment.
Ich habe mich gefragt, warum haben denn die Schriftarten,
die ich hier verwende,
warum sehen die alle gleich aus? Und warum sieht
die, die ich hier verwendet habe, nicht
so aus, wie ich sie kenne? Ja,
weil ich die Schriftarten alle nicht richtig installiert
hatte und mir Tipps nicht gesagt hat,
dass diese Schriftart, die ich
an dieser Stelle verwende,
nicht da ist und er deshalb auf eine
Defort-Schriftart zurückgefallen ist.
Aber wer weiß, vielleicht wird es mit der nächsten Version
auch schon besser. Also Tipps ist ganz cool.
Ja, und die Syntax ist, also das, was man als Dokument hat, ist so schön, vergleichbar zu lassen.
Also ich habe hier mal so ein Template offen, da werden ein paar Funktionen definiert und ich muss sagen, ich habe mich noch nicht damit auseinandergesetzt, dieses Template selber zu editieren, es ist immer noch recht weird, ich habe mich mit der Typst-Syntax selber noch nicht intensiv auseinandergesetzt, aber es ist in sich konsistenter als Latex-Makros.
Gut, wollen wir es dabei belassen?
Wir können uns ja noch ein paar Sachen für die nächste Folge aufheben.
Können wir auch machen.
Dann machen wir das so.
Dann schreibt uns doch mal in unserem Matrix-Channel oder auf Mastodon.
Ja, oder in den Kommentaren auf unserer Webseite.
Die drei Möglichkeiten haben wir.
Ob ihr Home Assistant nutzt, was ihr für Integrations verwendet.
Was der größte Pain-Point ist.
Erklärt uns den größten Pain-Point, bitte.
Oder was wir für scheiße gelabert haben.
Und ihr wisst es natürlich besser und
bitte erklärt uns, was ihr besser wisst,
damit wir von eurer Weisheit lernen können,
was in Bezug auf
Home Assistant
oder Minecraft.
Deswegen machen wir
diesen Podcast, um unser gefährliches
Halbwissen in die Welt zu blasen und
Gesagt zu bekommen, das ist so.
Die einfachste Möglichkeit
im Internet etwas
an Informationen heranzukommen
oder etwas zu lernen ist, etwas
Falsches zu behaupten. Ja, das ist AdWords Law.
Also es ist nicht Edwurts Law, aber das sage ich jetzt damit, dass korrigiert werden, wie es heißt.
Weil ich vergessen habe, welche Law das ist.
In dem Sinne, das war Akronomisierbar, Folge 57.
Der nächste Podcast in eurem Podcatcher beginnt in 3, 2, 1.
Plup!
Sehr schön.
Conway's Law.
*laughter*